Trudeau's Crackdown has begun the
freedom Convoy is being cleared out
members of the press are being arrested
a live streamer while streaming was
arrested clearly not doing anything
wrong this is it's obvious at this point
is an abusive power they were supposed
to be debating the emergency act powers
that should I was going to be using and
they shut it down because apparently
Trudeau decided I'm going to use them
anyway now there's video coming out
reports that a woman was trampled by a
horse members of the media being
arrested it's just it's gone a little
too far but I do think y'all should be
optimistic here because it shows the
protests worked they're working and I
don't think it ends here in the United
States we're hearing there's going to be
a convoy leaving from Barstow California
heading to Washington DC and the D.C
police are rescinding leave for officers
because they were preparing for this so
let's let's get into all that we'll talk
about what's going on but we also have a
lot of cultural stories to talk about
things about you know wokeness in in
movies and video games we'll talk about
Brian Cranston saying he's having like a
woke Awakening or some ridicul less
nonsense and we're being joined by a
refugee out of Hollywood who's now
working with the daily wire so this
would be a really great conversation we
have Dallas Sanjay how's it going man do
you want to introduce yourself yeah
absolutely we're gonna make up a little
bit sorry I'm a uh I'm a movie producer
uh who is making all the daily wire
movies now uh I spent 16 years in Los
Angeles I'm best known for uh bone
Tomahawk with Kurt Russell brawlins Cell
Block 99 with Vince Vaughn uh dragged
across concrete with Mel Gibson wow and
then I made a movie called run height
fight and even though it got a standing
ovation in the Venice Film Festival uh
no one would buy it right all of the
executives at all the Distributors that
I've worked with and made a lot of money
for in the past they've got kids in
public schools they've got mortgages
they didn't want to take the heat
internally so they passed on the movie
and I was
saying what am I going to do but I'd had
a coffee with Ben Shapiro the year
before I called him up and the rest is
history wow and now you've got uh shut
in as well yep and there's a tear on the
Prairie I think that's what's called we
had Nick Cersei on recently so uh this
is fantastic stuff because you know with
with the the escalation and the cultural
conflict building infrastructure is
extremely important but building culture
is is probably more important so
absolutely I think what daily wire's
been doing with picking up these movies
and and producing more is is brilliant
and we'll get in all that stuff so
thanks for joining us we're also being
joined by Brett dasovic of Pop Culture
crisis yes uh that is true I'm a refugee
of my own sort uh out here uh coming out
here to work
what's weird about this to me is like uh
I don't think I ever imagined coming on
here like uh doing the show like doing
it feels like I was telling Miracle
earlier I was like kind of feels like
I've elevated to the big leagues from
the upstairs Studio to the downstairs
studio uh and we cover a lot of these
topics uh we try to keep it as uh open
in perspective as possible but we're
going to get into a lot of that tonight
I'm excited yeah yeah so for those that
aren't familiar we've we launched a
couple other shows at timcast.com one of
which is pop culture crisis and Brett is
the host so you know this basically
happens I think we were driving back
from a movie and then Brett was talking
the whole time I'm like man this guy
knows everything he knows all that movie
he was naming directors and producers
and like he was you know and production
assistants he just like knew the credits
and I was like Brett you want to do a
show talking about this stuff and he
said yes I literally thought he was like
God he's never gonna shut up if you just
give him a show if we just give him a
show like he'll just leave us alone and
we can drive home in peace it'll be
perfect send him upstairs and talk about
the stuff on camera and make money off
of it Brett's also an incredible skater
you can check out his stuff on Instagram
Brett dasovic I'm really glad you're
here man because I've been thinking a
lot about memetic Warfare and fifth
generational Warfare and I think that
what's happening is that the message has
become the communication it's less about
the ideas and more about the way we're
communicating and I think acting is a
super important way to communicate and
to get people on your side basically
this is a it's a good point as to why
culture is so relevant because uh we
were talking about this the other day
with Stephen Martian and Civil War stuff
but mimetic Warfare propaganda
information and culture building you got
to have content you got to have
um TV shows movies video games all that
stuff outside of the infrastructure to
support it yeah variety be able to be
adaptable you know you the way you
communicate should be adaptable and I
think as an act being an actor can help
show people that you you are adaptable
so we'll yeah we'll get in all that
stuff we got Lydia as well I'm here as
well I'm so excited to have Dallas this
evening and I'm really excited to have
Brett I think that with the daily wire
is doing with movies is so important I
think it's pivotal to have movies that
are in interesting to people and I love
the idea of having this analysis of the
culture going on as well which I love
what pop culture crisis is doing so I'm
excited for this evening it's gonna be
fun before we get started
head over to timcast.com and become a
member and I will also also just briefly
mention someone chatted is that an
abacus in front of Ian yes it is
certainly is go to timcast.com be a
member help support the work we're doing
as a member you'll get access to
exclusive episodes of this show that are
just for members only but also you're
making sure the people who report here
the people who work here have jobs we've
got on the ground reporters we've got
field reporters we are planning out
sending someone to embed I say in bed
but you know drive along the U.S Convoy
and track what's happening as they make
their way across the United States we
are in the preliminary discussions about
doing that but it's all possible because
you guys sign up as members so don't
even think about it as you know for
those of you that just want to sign up
to get the members only stuff by all
means do that for everybody else think
of it as a pay what you will if you if
you like the work we do if you like the
Articles if you like the show just being
a member makes sure we can keep doing it
and it is greatly appreciated so don't
forget smash that like button subscribe
to this Channel right now on YouTube
Share the show with your friends let's
get started talking about the big news
is out of Ottawa what's happening with
this with this Crackdown Daily Mail
reports Trudeau's trucker Crackdown
begins hundreds of cops backed by
armored vehicles and horses arrest at
least 100 Freedom Convoy protesters in
Ottawa and Tow 21 big rigs using
emergencies act power so we got a bunch
of photos out of here mounted officers
showing up people screaming you've got
plane you've got regular you know looks
I don't know if these are like Community
officers or what they're not wearing arm
or anything like that but here you've
got what appeared to be some kind of
riot control armed with tear gas gas
masks look at this guy look I've seen
this stuff throughout my time I've seen
it at violent riots I've seen it at well
mostly violent riots typically when I
see peaceful protesters you might see
stuff like this but you don't see this
the severity I've certainly seen police
brutality at peaceful protests
especially from the left don't get me
wrong but this seems to be absolutely
overplayed and extreme for a bunch of
you know middle-aged truckers and
families with their kids and dogs and
about and a bouncy castle I understand
people are like well sometimes there's
there's confrontations yeah come on it's
a peaceful occupation in a city they
should be coming in with like 10
officers peacefully saying look guys you
know you broke the law we're going to
take you in slap on the wrist instead it
is Trudeau fascism Crackdown freezing
people's assets trampling people with
horses
dark days indeed huh is this the group
that had the bouncy house outside the
yes uh very scary nothing scarier than a
bunch of middle-aged truckers with a
bouncy house for their kids uh that is
what I live in fear of we think you
think you're joking but no seriously
they don't know how to respond to it
when when you get a violent Riot the
state says oh thank heavens because they
know that they're going to earn public
support for shutting down riots even
when they barely do it but when you got
little kids in a bouncy house they're
like whatever we do it's gonna look
really really bad how do we handle this
they do get scared of that stuff I
suppose it's kind of like in the past
when they would have kids at the front
lines of the protests or the riots right
to uh to prevent police action right
it's the left does it all the time it's
an Optics thing yep yeah they're even
threatening to go after journalists this
is like uh uh how a monarchy doesn't
know how to respond to a peaceful
protest they talk about Canada's all
about and I'm not saying Canada is the
monarchy but the queen could stop this
if she wanted they talk about like peace
we need calm this and peace you guys and
then when stuff like this breaks out
they don't know what to do because it's
this fake you know this platitude of
kindness and peace you guys know this is
fascist militant you know
quasi-democracy so now we're seeing the
true colors of how in America we fight
each other for fun that's and so we
don't get to this point because we know
how to deal with protest it's like this
country is a protest it's something you
told me it's a great way to look at uh
our species the way it functions the way
the importance of resistance
this is bothering me
yeah
dark days indeed now I wonder what will
happen in the U.S because uh you know
D.C police are saying they're gonna uh
they're pulling leave because they're
worried about this as well I can't say
I'm surprised about Canada though uh for
those that didn't get the episode
yesterday we had a Canadian Guy Stephen
Marshawn he wrote a book about Civil War
and I think his perspective is really
interesting I think I disagree with him
to a great deal but he was basically
saying in the United States there's two
countries a multicultural democracy and
a constitutional republic and I was like
wow that's that's a that's an excellent
way to point out what's happening and of
course the United States isn't always
has been a constitutional republic
therefore the Multicultural democracy he
speaks of is supplanting our our culture
our country our society and that's very
much what Canada is Canada has been for
a long time he mentioned how you know
Canada is very unstable and he was
surprised the US was destabilizing and
I'm like the U.S has been stable because
we are a constitutional republic it's a
safeguard to make sure there's you know
from from the smallest jurisdiction and
up people have representation yeah you
don't it doesn't seem like you get that
with Canada it seems like they just
don't care about you you're a cog in
their machine
if you watch Canadian Parliament that
was that was the feeling I got it's it's
like a clown show like it's dudes
wearing a big white puffy outfit and
you're like what in the hell and then
they start they Heckle each other like
how can you get any it's the weirdest
ancient practice tradition or whatever
the hell but it is not like stable well
I I I was uh doxed this week as a
contributor to the freedom Convoy Gibson
go uh congratulations yeah I was
actually quite proud of it it was a it
was a positive experience I was so proud
uh but I've I've been team Convoy since
day one on this and it it means so much
to so many of us I look at Australia I
look at Canada I look at even Italy my
favorite country to visit and I don't
even recognize these places and it makes
me so proud to be an American in a red
State I live in Texas work in Tennessee
vacation in Florida my last two years
have been basically okay outside of all
the numbers but you were you were in
California you were in California for
for 15 years now back then would you
have dared speak up in support of this I
would have but uh I knew the tide was
turning so heavily that in 2014 I left I
took my whole family and went back to
Texas oh so you got out early oh I saw
it all coming I couldn't have told you
what was coming but I felt it coming I
know exactly what you're talking about
yeah because I was living in New York
and I kept slowly moving away because it
just seemed to be getting worse and
worse until we end up in West Virginia
or you know this whole area yeah yeah
because I don't want to be in a big city
and then you look at what happens with
the lockdowns so we were actually we
moved to this to South Jersey and then
when they did the hard lockdown I was
like we got to get out of here like I'm
not going to sit around and wait to find
out how bad it does get and and it got
bad we had we had those wrestlers back
in 2020 the riots crossed the bridge
from Philly into South Jersey and I was
like yo I'm done with that I'm getting
out we're going to the middle of nowhere
we're gonna do our own thing we're gonna
build our own space not to mention I'll
be completely honest way cheaper out
here for land so expanding the business
there's way more opportunity but I think
there's a huge opportunity and pushing
back from a lot of the stuff by
rejecting it when we see this going down
in Canada my I have one thing to say to
all of this confidence in the system is
being broken right if if you can't even
uh I'm look I can't speak for Canada I
don't know what Canada does but uh for
us down here we see what's happening
with the vaccine mandates they're kind
of being shattered or you know how bad
it's been
talk about multiple Multicultural
democracy or whatever but when you
cannot get a redress of grievances
you're looking at a hard fall for for
your society when you look at the
dysfunction in Congress when you look at
the fact that it's being run by people
like Nancy Pelosi I'm just like that is
shattering I'm gonna I'm gonna go and
start setting up something somewhere
else to get away from this because to
put it simply confidence in the system
be it Canada be it the UK be it the EU
be the United States it's fracturing and
so it's time to make sure that you were
Shoring up our defenses we're building
something substantive on our own that we
control that's that's going to be
isolated from this otherwise it shatters
along with it
I hope that the freedom Convoy thing if
nothing else I really hope that it
shatters people's normalcy bias this
understanding this thinking that it
can't happen here because trust me I I
never thought I would see something like
this in Canada Canada is the nicest
place in the world they never do
anything crazy or edgy this is wild to
me what like literally watching them
tonight the videos going around Twitter
of the Mounted Police
um just literally walking over people I
want to give a good shout out to my
conservative friends who uh specifically
not all I'm not saying all conservatives
the ones who defended Ron DeSantis and
Florida passing the the the anti-riot
bill that would make it a felony to
block roads I said no you don't want to
do that because we want to tolerate some
degree of unrest because now we see what
happens in Canada and we're going to be
seeing what happens with the DC protest
with this with this Convoy I think we
should respect people who want to
peacefully obstruct it's annoying but we
tolerate a certain give to the system
you need that flexibility otherwise if
it's too brittle it shatters but I also
want to shout out a lot of these
conservatives um Ezra Levant I think it
was had a great tweet where he said it
used to be back to Blue he would always
give the cops the benefit of the doubt
now he's seeing what they're doing to
trampling old women and in front of
children and I'm like I gotta tell you
man
there are a lot of moderate there are a
lot of there are a lot of liberals who
have been saying exactly this for some
time now I get it when you get black
lives matter and often lying lying in it
to incite violence the Michael Brown
stuff was a lie the Trayvon Martin stuff
was a lie Ahmed Arbury stuff was a lie
George Floyd's stuff was alive I get it
you're like I'm not gonna believe these
people and I totally agree I'm not going
to believe him either but I'll tell you
this when I was in Ferguson I saw police
just lob a flashbang into a crowd of
people unprovoked I've seen and there's
videos of things like this this stuff
happens so there's a certain degree that
I'm willing to tolerate because I think
policing is an important institution but
you get to the point where they're not
stopping the rights in these big cities
the big cities vote for this they they
they're the ones rioting they're the
ones supporting these Mayors and these
Democrats and these appointees they're
the ones cheering on the police
defending the illegal seizure of funds
to paint political message in the street
and I'm just like why would I defend any
of these cops from the writers when
they're a part of that same system then
you see other cops come in and shut down
small businesses over coveted lockdown
and I'm just like okay that's it I'm out
look duly elected law enforcement seems
to do a really great job sheriffs you
know I we have a great relationship with
our cops out here but these big city
cops are basically part of that
Multicultural democracy establishment
Democrat machine they can they can live
however they want to live I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna intervene when they try to
defund those departments or now in
Austin where they're arrest they're
indicting 19 officers an aggravated
assault I'm like you know what I don't
want to live in Austin you all voted for
that congratulations officers you get it
I understand the isolation mentality and
I was thinking about this a lot too
because if if we really hit like a bad
place of civil war or like where all the
power went out you'd get roving bands of
militants that are like really good at
what they do it's called uh uh I don't
know what you call it but not imbalanced
War what do they call it where like one
side is way better than the other side
asymmetrical asymmetrical War you'll get
people they'll go from house to house
and raid every how they'll be like 12
guys with machine guns or or semi-autos
raiding house by house to get all the
valuables and like everyone these
Americans are like I got my guns I'm
safe I'm gonna stay here in my house but
you're a sitting Target these people
know how to conquer and control and
there will be so I understand the desire
to isolate but those kind of things will
come for you if you try and isolate you
have it is good to be out in in the
country and have space but isolation is
not the answer you need to be involved
consciously with your fellow man that's
where we do movies and TV and music and
internet video and things like that
you're you're right I agree and what
what I would say
I don't think the goal should be to try
and infiltrate their systems you know
for a long time moderates left
libertarian like left liberal
libertarian types have been complaining
about movies and video games getting
woke and doing all this other stuff
because they genuinely believed they
were in the same system with these
people when I say to you I don't like
your video game because you did these
things it is because I believe genuinely
we're working together as one Society on
a product I think people need to realize
they're not treating you that way and
they don't care what you think and
they're gonna do whatever they want in
which case you don't want to isolate
yourself you want to make something
better on your own and attract the
people who are disillusioned by them to
come and join you as one civilization as
one Society that's exactly right and I
and I spent enough time in Hollywood to
understand that and that's something I
feel very passionately about a year ago
when I went on Ben's Sunday special I
talked about parallel economies and this
is so important to me because a parallel
Hollywood wood is in my opinion the only
answer right there are not uh ways for
me to get the movies that I want to make
politics aside in traditional Hollywood
right now they're not supported in fact
they're discouraged or even disallowed
and so I had to go and try to create a
parallel economy where I wasn't going to
get attacked I wasn't going to get uh
you know I wasn't going to be tolerated
I was going to be celebrated and you
know we're just getting started but it's
game on right now well so uh the the
first movie you you actually made uh run
was it run hide from hide fight but you
didn't make that with daily wire correct
they bought it yes so this is a movie
that uh you produced yes and it's about
a young woman and there's a school
shooting
so this I I'm I'm surprised you even got
that made in the current environment to
be bought by daily wire like how does
that happen our company paid for the
movie itself ourselves wow so we have
investors and they uh you know bet on me
and so what happened was we made the
movie we got you know great cast Thomas
Jane Rhonda Mitchell uh Isabelle May
who's now the star of 1883 the uh
Yellowstone prequel
and we went and made the movie by
ourselves totally independently and
right as I after I made it I was in Los
Angeles and I had a coffee with Ben
Shapiro and I said I would talk to him
about the movie and he was very excited
about it and at the end of the coffee I
said let's make movies together he said
really he I said yeah let's do it he
said well okay well we can help you in
the background you know but if you put
our name on it you're gonna get killed
you crazy I'm gonna put your name all
over it you know I actually want to ask
a question about that so you the Run
height fight was produced uh beforehand
and then they bought it so then did they
have to do press tours for this with the
actors and were the actors hesitant
about being involved with the daily wire
so like you said Ben mentioned before
he's like you got you we he even before
he asked said we'll do it in the
background because he just assumes he
knew that they're not going to want to
be that you're not going to want their
name involved certainly
uh
uh we had we had gotten a movie into
Venice which is uh next to Canon
Sundance the most prestigious film
festival in the world and we got a
standing ovation and all that kind of
stuff but when we walked out our text
messages from our publicist started
coming in F you know zero out of ten how
dare you right personal politics right
all these things and so I knew we were
in big trouble yeah so uh by going with
Ben the movie found its best by going
with daily wire the movie found its best
home that also meant that some of the
actors couldn't I couldn't ask them to
support the movie publicly beyond their
comfort zone
and some of the some of the actors
supported the movie some of the actors
supported the movie
uh sort of privately quietly and others
just sort of tuned out
um they're all be becoming big stars
right now and they all kind of love it
right they all kinda because they knew
they were in Venice when we all saw a
great movie and then Standing Ovation
you said Standing Ovation wow the fact
that they have to worry about it at all
is the most disturbing part of all of it
no no but they don't have to worry about
it they do they don't yes if they if
they were if they had the uh you're
you're both right they they do have to
worry about it but they don't have to
they right they shouldn't I'm saying
that as a point obviously they worry for
their careers I'm saying they shouldn't
for sure they they don't have to if they
choose not to these are not by any
stretch of the imagination impoverished
people
now that's right it's hard to ask
somebody to slash your income By Us by a
large percentages I mean look I get it
um I don't uh you know for a movie like
shut and I don't know I don't know if
these people are like a list or
celebrities with worth millions of
dollars but they get paid probably
substantially better than say you know
Tradesmen or someone working at
Starbucks I'd imagine they do we we even
on shut in where we had the whole cast
in advance understanding who we were
making the movie with I mean we all went
to dinner before the movie started
shooting there was still an element of
right before the movie started coming
out and press time was on upon us people
started to get hesitant right uh yes uh
in in one case a publicist told one of
the actors involved in one of our movies
uh that we were queuing on right
and and and and and and and that we and
that she would have been canceled you
know this actress would have been
canceled right away
now maybe that's true maybe that's not
our opinion is you suffer through 72
hours of bad tweets and then the world
moves on right and you made the best
movie you've ever made in your career
Isabelle May is not the star of 1883
right now because Taylor shared and
watched Katie and Alexa or Alexa and
Katie on Netflix he watched our movie
and she's great in it and now she's a
massive star so uh you know it's a tough
thing I'll never ask anyone to do
anything they're uncomfortable with but
I will say and we'll get into Gina
Carano in a minute Gina we're working
with someone who is totally on board
from day one oh man that's good it's
fantastic that's just so great that
that's you know the fact that she was so
outspoken the entire time while while on
Mandalorian and I'm I'm following her on
Twitter and I'm just like this is
you just gotta not worry and be yourself
and stand up for what you believe in and
when they canceled her she was just like
I'll find a way and she and Ben and
bench up here on the daily wire we're
like we're gonna make this work you got
nothing to worry about it's a great
story if you don't mind I'll tell you
absolutely it's so terrific so I believe
that when when when someone like Gina
has the guts to do what she did
you have to pray that there are people
like me and daily wire ready to catch
you and that's not fully realized yet
right it's not it's not totally the
infrastructure is not all there yet
we're we're building ours but there
needs to be more
so Gina gets canceled on a Wednesday
night at 10 pm
I text Jeremy boring the CEO of daily
wire at 1005. and he texts me right back
Ben and I were just texting about this I
said dude keep your phone on tomorrow
morning I'm going to call you this is
going to move very fast just please keep
your phone on so I reached out to Gina's
agent who I used to work for the agent
said yeah we're dropping her I said oh I
said oh it's terrible I said well at
least give me her manager's phone number
so I reached out to the manager I'd
known him from my La days barely right
can you say which agency this was was it
a big five UTA United talent agency yeah
they're they're a top three for sure I'm
not a fan huge agency the same agent by
the way it still represents James Franco
who by the way I'd work with in a second
love him but yes James Franco is more
canceled than Gina Carano yet because
one gets dropped in one film school
stuff about the intimacy of course yeah
you know James come so you know it it
it's it's such a it's such a joke right
so I reach out to the manager who I'd
known back in LA
say hey uh let's get on the phone so we
spoke immediately he's like oh okay it's
like we're kind of just you know reeling
from all this we were gonna sort of take
a step back and like you know we're
getting calls from Megan Kelly and
Hannity and all the stuff I said no no
no two things one say no to all of it
number two you have to move now you have
to trust me I'm your guardian angel I'm
showing up daily wire and and we are
going to do this let's go so the next
morning
we got Gina on the phone with uh Ben
himself we got Jeremy and I on the phone
with the manager we banged out a deal
that day Dallas was in the middle of a
snowstorm where I live uh and then
Friday morning we announced it on
Deadline Hollywood that we did a movie
deal with her and that exploded more
than the original announcement so this
is how you fight you were right about
moving fast fast that boosted morale by
Monday the story's passed it's it nobody
cares it's that fast so we had to she
got fired Wednesday night 10 p.m by 10
a.m Friday morning the announcement and
she had yes man we gotta we gotta get
Tim cast films going oh we have to yeah
when you're talking about we're we're
growing decentralizing or basically a
new Hollywood a parallel system how do
you envision that because I wonder
Hollywood centralized that was kind of
the point of it was there there's all
these big walled boom Stage Sound stages
and stuff so do you want to put them all
over the place well we're all in
Nashville definitely it has to grow in
ecosystem almost taking the role of an
old Hollywood studio system so we would
have multiple screenwriters uh you know
uh that we would pay full salaries to
right they can make more money that way
anyway full benefits all this kind of
real jobs writing and directing movies
do you think do you think we need to
build like localized sound stages
absolutely Nashville has a few and we've
used them and they're pretty good
they've got uh you know some some really
nice ones but they still don't have one
that's competitive with Atlanta or
Albuquerque yet
okay what's that gonna run we can talk
about that stuff off air I guess yeah
500 million whoa okay yeah but uh for a
full ecosystem I mean that's Netflix
money so what our what our move right
now is baby steps right I came my my
sort of emotional gift to daily wire in
many ways is that I'm going to work on
these movies as if my life depends on
them right because they can't be bad if
they're bad we will get shunned mocked
all this kind of stuff they're still
going to attack us and they are there's
some amazing articles that came out the
last few days about us but like you know
trying to poo poo the movies but these
articles exist because they're scared
who cares about them I love it this is
what this is what I'm saying if there's
somebody who's like Ghostbusters 2016
was a great accomplishment by all means
go watch Ghostbusters 2016. enjoy it I'm
very happy for you I'm gonna go watch
run hide fight or or shut in and enjoy
myself yeah and if you want that
Hollywood you can do whatever you want
but but I'm saying
if they keep going down this path I
think it's very obvious that their
system is going to crumble we the the
the gentleman we had on the other day
Stephen even mentioned that when
institutions start getting woke they
start falling apart right and he's a guy
who has a very establishment world view
on things very critical of the far right
as you would call it but even he
recognizes media companies are moving
left and once they do it starts just
crumbling so if Hollywood wants to get
woke and go broke by all means I'm not
going to complain about it oh let him if
I if if my neighbor wants to go swimming
with alligators I'm going to be like I
will advise against it but far be it for
me to tell you what risks you can't take
now we'll go over here we'll make some
good movies and have some fun and make
jokes and not have to worry about being
canceled every two seconds and then I
think 10 years from now the work you're
doing the work bench up here on the
daily wire is doing is planting a tree
whose shade you will actually get to sit
beneath and so will your children that
is the hope that is the entire hope that
is what this is all about it's to it's
to create infrastructure and ecosystem
for people who are willing to take risks
and fight the system knowing they can do
do that get canceled and come over here
and work with us it's also really
important that we make great movies so
this is sustainable it has to make money
right so we're making movies that are
small but you know big idea little box
on purpose but we're growing quickly I
mean the budgets are already moving up
we're going to get into series all these
kind of things so
it's game on well it's like it's going
to take Trailblazers and the writing in
the production part too because like you
said like Gina walks away uh as an actor
those same people who have been told
that they have to live within the
Hollywood ecosystem are going to have to
walk away and know and feel strongly
enough about the work they create that
they believe that that uh that that
script that that show can stand on its
own two legs no matter where it's put
out not through the perceived legitimacy
of Hollywood but through any form of
media that it can come out through and
the story uh is what elevates it not the
uh the deadlines not the AV clubs in the
establishment press media that make
these things seem like they're better
than they are the you know yeah I think
we got to utilize piracy Game of Thrones
is like one of the most pirated shows of
all time and it was also one of the most
popular I think those that's not a
coincidence piracy is a tricky one
um uh when you're in a transactional
business VOD movies or even theatrical
you're so ins you're so reliant on that
purchase of that movie when you're in
the streaming world the money's coming
in and it's for a bunch of stuff right
in Daily wires case there's the
political uh folks that are you know
political members uh they're they're
watching the podcast and the political
uh content there's folks who are simply
fans of Ben or Candice Owens for example
and then there's the people who love the
movies and they're all going into one
Revenue stream and it's really working
from a financial perspective so the
company is super healthy it's run like a
real fortune whatever company a fortune
you know however many numbers company
and it's terrific and you walk in and
you're you cannot believe the feeling of
being surrounded by all of these people
who you know if they don't share your
exact same values they're civically
aligned they have the same goal which is
not to be the other side do you think
there's a value at running it at a loss
like selling on the moon for 99 cents uh
pop and taking like we are version 70
loss our version of that has been
opening night YouTubes so we play the
movies on YouTube One Night Only uh for
the first 20 you know for the first two
hours it's only available two hours in
fact if you start at 15 minutes late
you're gonna have to go watch the the 15
minutes on daily wires uh uh you know on
their site is there a way that they're
going to figure this out financially
like when we look at like we we break
down box office it's already it's
already cash flow positive okay but like
we break down box offices so in a studio
invest 100 million dollars they put 1.5
times that into marketing uh then they
have to look at their return on
investment for what they make at the box
office how are they going to be figuring
those numbers out when it comes to
streaming it's actually worse than that
you got to add in foreign sales you've
got to add and they only take 60 of the
box office even less if it's in China
the values of who your star is things
like that all of those pressure points
on making a great movie go out the
window so this is as close as you can
get to 1969 Easy Rider as I could
possibly imagine I mean it is the Easy
Rider most people don't know this but
Easy Rider and Five Easy Pieces and The
Last Picture Show and some of these
other great movies were all produced by
these three guys uh uh SBS and there's a
great Criterion Collection about their
works and these guys set up their own
shop they had their own deal with pair
uh with the Columbia TriStar at the time
and they made these great movies that's
all we're doing here we're just creating
sort of the most creatively unfiltered
version of Hollywood absolutely possible
today
I would like to think that once the work
starts coming out more frequently and
people can see that what they're
producing is not conservative media per
se it's just good media that as culture
turns people come with it and it becomes
less stigmatized yeah and and certainly
one day we'll be uh accused of making a
truly conservative movie like like I'd
love to make a comedy called Kamala
exclamation point you know like yeah
I mean come on I call it HBO films in
Reverse right I would love I would love
to do that at some point but not right
now but it's going to get labeled that
way but that's something you have to not
care that the like I said the deadlines
the AV clubs all these websites the
social media sets are going to call it
that just like they label religious
films yeah you know the way they sing
but paint all religious films with the
same brush you know there was a period
where I cared you know maybe a few years
ago worried about mainstream press their
reactions and like I was saying it's
because I felt like we were part of one
system together right and I didn't want
them I don't want my neighbor to feel to
to think bad things about me that don't
represent me
then I started to realize eventually
Like These people aren't our neighbors
anymore yeah and it's scary it's
unfortunate but uh I'm not interested in
trying to convince people who hate me
and refuse to listen when I try to be
nice to them yeah I'm actually what what
I've approached many of these people be
it on the ground in Portland at protests
or on Facebook and I'm nice to them and
their response is I literally don't care
what you have to say f you you fascist
I'm like okay then then I'm gonna go do
my thing over there you no longer factor
in so in these media Outlets say
whatever they want don't care we're
going to build our thing we're gonna do
a good job of it and guess what's gonna
happen like I said five ten years people
are going to be knocking down the door
desperate to get a role with daily wire
Productions with your company and I'll
tell you this too
look at Rumble right now I advise people
when they're like how do I want to make
a show I want to do YouTube videos no no
you want to do Rumble videos because
YouTube has pulled up the ladder behind
everybody else you're getting banned you
don't know what you can or can't say
live streamers get too popular too fast
they take you down start on Rumble
you've got more Market opportunity this
means in La there's going to be writers
there's going to be production
assistants producers smaller staff APS
whatever and they're going to say I
would rather move to Nashville because I
know there's a great opportunity with
daily wire and the stuff they're
producing and it's freeing but more
importantly the market opportunity
Hollywood is is such a monolith it's so
hard to break in you hear all these
stories about people sending a pizza
into producers when they open it there's
a there's a head shot don't even worry
about there's a real opportunity now
with what you guys are doing over at
Daily wire in your Productions so why
bother with trying to climb an ivory
Tower when you can go knock on the front
door of people who said we want to do
great stuff and we want to make make
something new here's your opportunity
you were telling us the story beforehand
about Tom Cruise negotiating his own
contract for Risky Business okay can you
explain that sir again because I want to
pull back to that yeah there was a
fantastic article on daily mail today uh
interviewing Tom Cruise's first manager
from when he was 18 to 22 or three and
uh Tom Cruise when he when he was
engaging on Risky Business sent an email
uh sorry sent a a letter uh to his agent
at CAA
telling her what to counter in the
negotiation the the fee down to the size
of the trailer everything involved and
it was just fascinating and it just goes
to show you what a movie star truly is
and so the the modern day business savvy
actors writers directors are going to
start see the tides turning see things
shift and they're going to see that
Nashville is just as a as a much of a
opportunity for them as it would be to
go straight to California and you would
hope that in there there's going to be
some script a couple of scripts here and
there that are going to be so good and
they're gonna stand out so well that it
will be that initial cultural shift that
uh that Touchstone that pushes things to
me you know to bring it back to back
this way absolutely and and and those
floodgates have have flung open right
I'm getting a phone call almost every
day now from an actor a director a
writer major major players people who
have Show run that's the head producer
on a TV show head writer of the some of
the biggest TV shows just saying I'm so
sick of this like please like what's
what's going on out there what are you
doing and then also I think we've become
very inspirational to a younger
generation of filmmakers I have this
rule I I answer every email so send me
an email Dallas bonfirelegend.com I will
I will write you back and you know I try
to respond to every single email quickly
sometimes it takes me a few days but I
want I want to to encourage these
filmmakers these young people who who
understand culture at the at that
generation better than I do to create
create and hopefully they can bring me
the right I guess we need to start
building tutorials on how how to use
sound equipment and lighting equipment
oh that's all over YouTube for sure good
have you looked into starting a new
Union I'm kind of fed up with sag I was
thinking about a web Actors Guild like
wag or something where you could decide
not to screw people over but also that
you don't have to pay them sure 1400 a
day or whatever the the the uh the
unions are are are sort of uh separated
into the crew and then what we call
above the line actors writers and
directors those three have their own
guilds sag wga DGA and then the crew is
uh under ayatsi and it's a really
challenging uh relationship for low
budget Independent Producers to work
with these unions they have for the most
part a reason to exist for the netflixes
of the world when it comes to a million
dollar movie it's very hard to engage
with them what I think the trick is is
if if we're going to sort of go further
out into the woods uh on these movies
and and and really make them on our own
we have to be good stewards right we
have to pay people fairly we have to
provide opportunities the other thing is
like especially with the stunt actors
their insurance is through sag so if
they get hurt doing a stunt and if
you've seen any of my movies there are
tons of stunts and every one of them
someone dies in every movie and and it's
like you know if if these people get
hurt they need the they need the
insurance to to protect their families
and still no Oscar for stunts could we
set up oh there should be that's a good
point dude
best part of movies in today's day and
age where stunts make up such a huge
percentage of the tent pull films that
we see and they get no recognition for
it whatsoever oh brilliant great yeah
that's a great idea instead why don't we
create our own Oscars stunts will be the
last the last one do it remember the
wiries they did like the the what was
the YouTube video award ceremonies they
started doing yeah
Benjamins and then like VidCon and all
that let's just start like a new in
Nashville absolutely not even I'm not
even you know you know what we do need
so uh are you familiar with VidCon yeah
there there are uh there was a year
where a bunch of Youtubers with big
followings showed up because their
political commentary cultural commentary
and they're shunned but I'll tell you my
story I actually uh had a big talent
agency reach out to VidCon it's back
when I was working for Disney when at
the Abc company and they're like hey Tim
pool is a streaming journalist we'd love
to get him involved and they said nope
don't care don't won't do it they end up
doing journalism panels with people who
aren't journalists and have no
followings and so I'm just like this is
an industry Insider game if you're a
friend of the people who run it they'll
claim you're a journalist and put you on
a panel for which you have no expertise
and have you talked to a bunch of people
it's just trash so you know what we do
need our own multimedia video social
media conference that actually talks
about Merit because that's what that's
what their whole system is about
authoritarianism the the the woke
Multicultural democracy is a religious
hierarchy if you are part of the party
you get privileged access
if the crowd decides who gets to to go
speak at it but then you got to avoid
popularity contests so there's going to
be well there should be some sort of
calculation that doesn't work because
you need uh you need if the people all
knew who say you were then why would
they need to see you go speak if they
know who you are because they've heard
you speak the the issue is if we're
doing a big event it's to introduce
people to experts in certain fields and
certain industries to tell them about
what's going on how you know here's what
you should learn here's what here's the
information I can give you the problem
with VidCon is they have like you know
they bring on this woman who has like a
thousand Twitter followers who doesn't
really work in journalism and then they
have her speak to an audience of people
as an expert I'm like why don't you
actually just reach out to people who
are experts and invite them to come so
that is the awoke authoritarianism if
you are a part of the cult they'll just
put you in a privileged position and
claim you're an expert makes no sense
but it's exactly what these regimes have
done in the past people who aren't
farmers are given Farms we need
meritocracy someone who's got proven
skills who's worked in the industry will
be invited to come speak and share their
knowledge the way it used to be remember
they hate meritocracy right the exact
idea of meritocracy well exactly you you
hit on it though because it used to be
be a situation where we were all in a
respectful relationship with each other
and the other sides and that is gone
these people hate you I say that all the
smile on your face these people
Hollywood hates you see I'm not talking
about you I'm talking about you and
everyone who doesn't just you know sort
of just just
to edit that I think they hate everyone
but here's where it gets weirder I get
also I get phone calls from my friends
who are still inside the system trapped
right and they're having to go to their
you know sessions and their uh biases
trainings and things like that and it is
they they have to play ball because
they're getting paid so much money that
to lose that salary right it's the it's
the freedom scale so the money holds
them hostage absolutely absolutely and
and and that's the only way they can get
a movie made they don't they don't know
how to come out and and risk it all and
all this kind of stuff but they're
starting to crack a little bit right
it's it's exciting right it's exciting
to see it what you guys are doing is
going to create a position where
Hollywood will be forced to to to to
mingle yeah to to cross over you're
gonna have uh the the latest film that's
a daily wire acquired is hyperions Right
Hyperion Perry Ellis one of my favorite
actors of all time when I when I saw
Jesus Pride what's up no for seriously I
love that when I saw the the Tweet come
out with the trailer and I'm like daily
wire got a carry out was film that is
that is impressive he's fantastic
sooner or later Hollywood's gonna say if
people are finding opportunity right
with this other new emerging you know
film industry we are going to we're not
going to be competitive if we put
constraints on them that the daily wire
guys don't so if the issue is right now
someone can choose to do a movie with
you guys and your position is will
always work with you and Hollywood
threatens them they're going to say you
know maybe I just go where it's easier
and less stressful Hollywood will be
forced to be alive no no no no no we
won't we won't Blacklist you we need
your talent too that's that's the market
competition you guys are bringing that's
what we need to see when I was in
Hollywood I worked with folks on the
left and folks on the right tons of them
right the folks on the right never had
an issue working with folks on the left
the reverse was so painful it was just
just constant complaining and this and
that and everything was a problem you
know I I remember coming in uh to work
one day after Trump was elected and half
the office was crying right and I just I
I thought to myself oh my gosh something
it like I don't understand this right I
don't even identify with with this
behavior and and and so then you know it
took me a little while to catch up to uh
where I was supposed to be which is you
know my optimized version now which is
hopefully you know making moves of the
daily wire for a decade plus I'd love to
you know I'm obviously considering
moving to Nashville and and and being a
really big even a bigger part of it than
I am now but I'm having a blast and and
it's it's so important uh to do this now
because I didn't I didn't I didn't grow
up as a 13 year old uh wanting to run
you know produce independent movies that
I'm producing now I thought I was going
to be running Paramount I thought I was
going to be the president production
Paramount like my idol Robert Evans kid
stays in the picture well you you you
technically will be yeah it just won't
be called Paramount that's great it will
be a major Studio producing some of the
biggest films in the world and it'll be
called something I thought the same
thing I was like I'm going to be Brad
Pitt and then I got just that sexuality
gross to me and I was like I gotta bail
on this Ian was in this but I'm still
commercial we can do it yeah we can make
we can become the biggest thing on earth
it's just not the way it seemed I want
to pull up this article from bounding in
a comments it's awesome dude yes
Godzilla actor Brian Cranston well Brian
Cranston is well known for a lot of
things claims he has white blindness
says he needs to learn and change in an
interview with the LA Times promotes
upcoming role as Charles Nichols in the
stage play power of the sale he revealed
he sufferers from what he calls white
blind blindness and advocated for limits
on Free Speech what
uh okay it's a privileged Viewpoint to
be able to look at the clan and laugh at
them and belittle them for their broken
and hateful ideology blah blah blah you
get the point you know this really is
this is he doesn't actually believe
anything no he's being held hostage
exactly he's being held hostage by his
by his manager by his agents by the
industry he needs to continue to be a
part of
Ben Shapiro I implore thee we must save
this man we must give him an opportunity
to say all that stuff was because they
made me say it I just want to make films
and we'll be like yeah you're cool right
on we were a fan or is he such a
capitalist yeah they are they're just
hyper capitalists yeah who are like you
know what if I have to do this to make
the money I'll do this to make the money
is he is he possibly worried that his
last two or three movies didn't go so
well and that if he does this he'll be
on front page he again
Breaking Bad was a terrible script what
I'm just gonna say that now
what were the last films he produced
well I'd have to look I haven't seen
anything from him yeah the Trumbo movie
2015 was not great he he killed him off
in act one in Godzilla look they're real
yeah I can't give specifics but we can
look it up but but it is inarguable that
he has been as relevant as he was when
Breaking Bad ended he's not then it
feels like almost so you've got the El
Camino the Breaking Bad movie okay fine
I love dogs you know the one and only
Ivan ladies night is something else
maybe it was the getting cast of Zordon
and Power Rangers that did him in
and I think you give him the opportunity
and you give him a path of success but I
wonder how much of what people are
chasing after his legacy and so the
issue is these people who live in the
cult genuinely believe that's the real
world and they View
actual America as a foreign entity and
something to be feared or something not
legitimate whereas you know the way we
described it especially yesterday
talking about the Civil War with um
Stephen uh Marsh there's a there's a
multicultural democracy in the United
States and a constitutional republic
they're at War they're at odds with each
other but the woke democracy is not the
real mainstream America it's something
weird and new that emerged in the past
15 or 20 years that's held in place by
the media that promotes it daily like
you don't realize that your average
neighbor does not believe the stuff that
you're watching on the news or that
you're seeing in these television shows
the average neighbor across from you is
a lot more reasonable than you would
think but they're held in these beliefs
are held in place by the mainstream
establishment press which has you know
your television holds a lot of weight in
your house the social media that your
kids look at holds a lot of weight you
know a lot of times when you talk about
when we talk about CNN like you'll talk
about the we talk about they rag on the
ratings of CNN right it's like it only
got 800 000 views this this episode
right I'm like yeah but these views are
parroted by celebrities each of who has
hundreds of millions of followers and
that pushes it outward to the general
public that's a good point they measure
only three million views but how many
retweets that show how many more views
that's a calculation that hasn't been
accurately done how many of the average
celebrity just watches CNN parrots those
beliefs and then every one of their
followers is uh you know or how many
Brian Cranston has an agent who comes
home and says look man you got to come
out and you got to say this stuff okay
it's going to be big you're going to get
a bunch of attention and he's like oh
okay I got a feeling he runs his agent
and that he actually got brainwashed I
saw it happen to a few other people
where one morning they wake up and
they're like yeah yeah whiteness is a
problem yeah I think LeBron James had
happened too all of a sudden yeah they
just want money you go to enough of
those uh those con those uh you know
those seminars they make you attend to
if you work for the government and I'm
sure you know more than a few of them do
end up starting to fall prey to it very
prevalent in Hollywood oh yeah and those
stories Tim like I see like 20 of those
a day when I'm looking when I'm when I'm
looking up stuff to talk about like a
lot of those I'll skip them I'm like you
know what it's it's so obvious like we
could cover that every day and I'd like
do I really need to rag on this yeah you
know the weirdest thing too is I'm sure
you can go to uh Brian cranston's um uh
history and find a whole bunch of racist
and off-color jokes and offensive comedy
and transphobia I mean there was uh
someone mentioned I saw on Twitter
SVU with uh you know NBC law order SVU
and that the main character Benson has
has been severely transphobic in a bunch
of different episodes or something I
don't know if that's true yeah because I
know that often these people lie or
exaggerate but I wouldn't be surprised
because it was a very different world 15
years ago the culture shifted I wonder
if this is actually you know he's got a
crisis management firm risk assessment
and they're like you know you did these
episodes of Malcolm in the Middle these
could come up invite you in the ass if
you come out now and and become devout
you'll be safe there are absolutely
examples of that and and in Hollywood if
you're if you're the most vocal about
you know being a sort of a male feminist
or any of these things never trust a
male family you have the you have the
worst history of you know dating and
past and things like that so that is
that is a rule I think in cranston's
case it literally is he was less uh uh
popular he's just less part of the
Zeitgeist he was fading yeah and he said
how can I get back on the front page
that how's it I think he's I think it
was that something so he decided to
figuratively self-immolate yes that's
right he was like I know
that is exactly what happened in my
opinion look at James Gunn got uh he he
had his tons of tweets that were really
creepy uh that we stuff we can't even
talk about on here and if you're part of
the establishment you get a pass because
what Disney did is they fired him DC
hired him and then Disney quietly
rehires him for Guardians of the Galaxy
3
I I wonder if it actually played out
um very very favorably for him I wonder
if he was actually quote unquote fired
by Marvel James gone I think it was Mike
cernovich who pulled up these tweets to
make a point about cancel calls Joe's
after Rosie O'Donnell right and Rosie
O'Donnell or Roseanne or Roseanne
Roseanne so you know he pulls up these
tweets from these like James Gunn used
to make those uh those movies those
really like gross horror films or
whatever they were called yeah and so he
has these really off-color offensive
jokes and I'm like and he's trying to be
an edge lord it's whatever but of course
it creates a media frenzy by quote
unquote firing him he was able to work
for for Marvel and DC you get to do both
you have to do both and Peacemaker came
out Great Peacemaker is fantastic we
loved it and um shout out to uh have you
seen Peacemaker oh yeah that's great so
uh I don't wanna I'm not gonna give too
deep of a spoiler but if you don't want
to hear it you're being warned I don't
think it's a spoiler I just want to say
the villains in that show are the
establishment Democrats I'm not even I'm
not even kidding they give a speech and
I'm just like climbing alarms that's
like back to factory like giving a
speech what is this it was like the bad
guys it was climate alarmism mixed with
Max mask propaganda yeah uh disguised as
aliens coming from another planet and
then they're the villains they're the
bad guys and I'm like I I actually
thought they were gonna try and pull
some like it turns out you know this
this whole authoritarian worldview is
the right idea but they're the bad guys
and I was like you know gotta respect it
you know what we got to do create a
movie where we've already as a species
with learned how to withdraw the carbon
dioxide from the atmosphere and fix the
climate change thing to create graphene
with it and we're building new materials
but now we're competing with trees for
the carbon dioxide and it's a new
problem and the trees become the trees
become sentient immobile yeah but that
way it'll implant in people's minds like
hey it's not that big of a problem by
the way climate change we can fix the
climate if we get proactive about it
well well to get a little bit more
broader it is a big problem that we can
is to get a little bit more broad on
your point this is the purpose of of
culture is um run height fight for
instance was about like standing up in
in defiance like you know fighting for
what you believe in and saving people
and things like that these are cultural
messages it was um you know I haven't
seen it but I've seen the trailer and
there's like this young girl she's being
trained how to use a weapon stuff like
that there's there's a photo going
around of kids in Wyoming being in a gym
with airsoft pellet guns uh I'm sorry
not Airsoft with pellet uh CO2 uh um
compression rifles
and I'm like my my joke about it was I
am disgusted and offended these children
should be outside with 22s putting them
in a gym with CO2 what are you doing
give him a 22 come on it's it's but um
the the establishment Democrat activist
reveal is shrieking children with guns
and there's like there's this video from
Libs of tick tock of a guy screaming
what are you insane and I'm like yo guns
are things like we we used to teach kids
how to be safe and respect them and
understand them and I was I think that's
a good idea so when you make a movie
that shows someone teaching you know a
young person how to use a weapon that is
creating the idea it's planting in
people's minds this is a this is a part
of life it's a normal part of life
that's the purpose of building culture
so you're writing yeah not a movie about
showing kids how to make guns but in the
movie The Character you love is showing
kids like as is teaching people proper
technique and so then you understand
that these things are a normal part of
the world so and your in your view about
Solutions towards climate change and
stuff like that making movies showing
possibilities opens people's minds up
too things they may have not considered
before which is why it's so important if
you seed culture only to the left the
woke you're going to get movies like men
have you seen the new craft
the craft you know you know the original
the craft oh I know all about it you've
seen the new one yep it was what it was
uh I don't even think you can call it a
movie no it was it was a a grouping of
random woke PSAs that don't seem to go
together at all the cast of spell turn a
guy gay or something I'm just like this
is not a movie it makes no sense but if
kids grow up watching that stuff their
brains are going to be all jumbled up
and broken from this nonsense one of the
biggest producers in Hollywood uh was
caught in an interview saying he didn't
know any female directors even even
though a female had just directed a
movie for him wow and so of course he
got called out semi-cancel for about 10
hours 10 hours and then back back and he
was back because he's such a big
producer and so his his sort of uh uh
you know his way of fixing things was to
put a bunch of female movies into female
directed movies into production the
problem is he didn't go and oversee
those movies the same way that he did
his mail Direction be allowed to he let
these women go on set and and and and
you know by themselves and and the
movies failed black Christmas in the
crowd that's so bad and it's and it's
honestly really sad and so all he well
while he was applauded for hiring all
these female directors the truth is he
let them fail that's like Biden's
Afghanistan withdrawal are you are you
familiar with the exactly are you
familiar with kindergarten story about
the clown no uh a fire breaks out
backstage at a theater and the clown
runs on stage to begin to warn the
audience of the fire and they'll begin
laughing he then becomes more erratic
and extreme no you need to understand
they all laugh even louder and he says I
think that's how the world will end with
people believing it's a joke or
something that effect and I wonder if
you know I think about that when I see
this guy he he puts these female
directors in play just because they're
females doesn't oversee them the movies
are abysmal and flop and then everyone
cheers for him I wonder if what's
actually happening is the people in the
audience know there's a fire they don't
care though because they're all worried
about being the one person to not clap
while everyone else is clapping one of
the female writers on one of the two
movies started to talk about this
phenomenon on Twitter and quickly
stopped oh yeah you know was sort of
encouraged not to do that anymore you
know is that the girl that was talking
to Jeremy Hamby the quartering I saw a
good diet I don't I don't think so
Jeremy's terrific she wrote um the girl
that's writing The Witcher I think
decided to strike up a dialogue with
Jeremy on Twitter or video chats so they
were really talking about I was like hey
yeah diversity is important but within
like one skin color you can have a lot
of different cultural diversity don't
forget that when you're creating well
well uh well no good yeah I was gonna
say they got the guy the producer went
further and created a deal with Amazon
to make low low budget uh horror movies
where he could get his diversity quotas
met so that he could go back to making
Halloween with a white male does it
actually have quotas or is a personal
thing of his it's a little uh it's all
it's all it's all all it's all part of
the it's all part of the unspoken rule
of Hollywood that's now more spoken to
be to be frank it's like the identity
politics version of like Wes Craven
saying he'd only do horror films so
they'd let him make a classic Love Story
yeah and like and he does what they say
the things they request of him uh with
no passion for it whatsoever although I
love the new Joker movie uh you know uh
uh the uh Todd uh the director uh he
wanted to make Taxi Driver yep it's what
he made so he made it yeah but let's
just make a good movie and call it
Jokers Todd Phillips you put it in you
put it in a joker storyline and now you
get 70 million dollars to make the movie
instead of seven 55 million dollars made
a billion without China but Joker was
awesome it is it is Awesome Taxi Driver
is awesome but that's the trick right
it's it's happening with the new Batman
I'd like to make sure
in what's the new Batman movie the new
Batman movie is a 1970s it's you know
new American Cinema movie housed under
Batman no hopefully it's great that's
the that's the pitch yeah yeah but there
I think it will be because they're
letting Matt Reeves have run of his
production whereas the every other
Warner Brothers production they've done
they've interfered so heavily that's uh
that's a that's a party line right uh
who knows but that's that's what they're
pitching uh uh and and Robert Pattinson
is a great actor yes you know so the
lighthouse Joker was I saw Joker in
theaters the media tried destroying it
they claimed it was incel yeah that's
why it made a billion dollars and but
but I went to see it and it's a it's a
it's really amazing how what the movie
is just the uh for I hope everybody's
seen it because that no I haven't seen
it but tell me I've watched so many
people I've seen it yeah I've seen a lot
of Clips pending is like it's I've seen
the end it's not action it's not I mean
there's action in it but Terror it's not
superheroes grow the ending is just
psychological Thriller edge of your seat
shaking the Joaquin Phoenix's
performance my heart like leapt from my
chest and that final scene and I was
just like I gotta watch this movie again
wow it was amazing and and it was it was
you know for what it was you say it's
like taxi driver with the joker
storyline but still it did Joker very
very well as the Joker character yep I
would I would love to see them use that
version of The Joker in in future
iterations of of DC uh films because
that is an excellent Joker he would fit
within the Matt Reeves uh version of
those characters I don't know if he
would fit as well into the standard DC
EU given that it's far more uh
whedonized no he would he it would be
amazing I'd rather see him in mattress
look I watched I watched The Dark Knight
recently and that version of The Joker
is absolutely incredible but very
magical right like how he pulls these
things off like all of a sudden he's got
two fairies rigged with explosives like
how did the Joker do that why why are
people working for this guy who's broke
he stole money from the mob but he's
he's he's Reckless so much so that the
the mob guy Maroney I think it is he's
like I can't do this craziness I'm gonna
help the police now
it it was it was an excellent portrayal
it was a fun movie but it was magical
this version of The Joker they actually
made it make sense why are people
following him ideology because he was
bucking the system and he's out of his
mind but people are like I don't care
anymore I absolutely love it I think
he'd be fantastic that makes so much
sense about why people why joker as a
following in Gotham City because
Gotham's always been like
post-apocalypse it's basically like the
worst New York could become and you can
see that's great great observation I
actually like Batman Begins more than
the Dark Knight visually because I think
it actually captures what Gotham is
supposed to look like once it became the
Dark Knight and then the Dark Knight
Rises it just became New York and
Chicago mixed together whereas there was
far more uh a far more ethereal dark
tone here's here's what really gets me
with with Joker is the people protesting
the not the one percent they're outraged
they're they're their their their lives
are miserable there's crime and they're
driven by ideology so when I think of
superheroes having to fight crazed
masses I'm like I actually understand
how you can't reason with far-left
extremists on the ground smashing
windows they're they're blinded by
hatred and zealotry and as a superhero
you you're sworn to protect them yeah
how does Batman fight them he doesn't he
not real not really well no Batman gives
him TBI he bashes their skulls in and
leaves them rotting and shivering on
them you know a guy stealing the loaf of
bread in Batman the meme oh yeah yeah
but but I'm thinking about how they
would do the new Joker in in a future
Batman movie is the followers of the
Joker are just ideologues who are like
you know Bruce Wayne is corrupt the
Batman supports the police the police
are crooked this system needs to be torn
down world baby from the ash exactly
From the Ashes of the old we shall build
Anew and the Joker is the one to do it
and then you get order of the Batman I
think that Hong Kong there's uh elements
of like Court of owl's story being
brought into this meaning that there's a
lot of possibility that the the Wayne's
end up being corrupt in the in the new
interpretation of the film which could
lend itself to that even better uh
because you know he can't fight back as
Bruce Wayne then because his parents
star because and and you know like in
the Joker Thomas Wayne looks kind of bad
yep so I I think I'm so impressed with
with Joker and uh they've done like
Jared Leto come on you know no
disrespect I think you know I don't know
about that weird stuff he's doing with
those women or whatever as well as weird
stories about him in Hollywood but uh uh
Fight Club big fan him is the Joker not
so much so in Batman are they is the
Joker who's up against the one percent
like against the Wayne's because they're
part of the one percent because that's
the cool storyline or the people that
follow the Joker are they against the
Wayne's have they focused the hatred
onto the wins okay in the film he thinks
Thomas Wayne is his dad and he's he's
just schizophrenic and so he's this
angry angsty deranged guy who snaps and
there's some sympathy for him the way
he's mistreated and abused and how he
goes off but the protesters just think
the system is broken and they see this
guy who goes on TV and says it to the
world and now he's got a he's got a
following and now the Joker from that
point becomes arrogant and and when he
says like now I see the humor in it I'm
like that is such a good Joker it's uh I
would love to see his Evolution into
legit super villain how his followers
support him because they agree with them
because they're driven by ideology
fantastic do you like the idea of them
doing it with William Defoe as like an
as like a faux Joker like a three Jokers
type storyline from the comics uh I
didn't think I didn't like that like I
don't want it to be any more like the
comics I want it to be like Nolan made
it it was basically crime dramas uh I
don't need it to be uh superhero-esque I
need it to be more like a standard
Thriller the way they did did Joker if
they went ultra realistic like Joker
doesn't have magic powers where he can
rig a fairy up but then you you deal
with you know the Batman or other
superheroes struggling to deal with
someone who's got such a large following
you don't know who is supporting them or
where you don't know how like what he's
doing and there's something to be said
about people who don't know how to play
a game and they're difficult to defeat
so if anyone's like plays poker there's
a certain difficulty in playing poker
against someone who has no idea what
they're doing they make weird bets yeah
you don't know if they're bluffing and
then they play 2-7 off suit and they hit
a full house and you're like we got it
what is it I saw the two and the seven
on the board I thought they'd never
played and they win so having that
erratic behavior of Joker would be a
really interesting you know they could
take that version we've got to be really
interesting against Bruce Wayne who's
where he like where Joker releases like
a bio weapon and can blame it on the bat
well I don't know about come on that's
the perfect
little bow to put on this conversation
not realistic well that's like that's
that's a joke about that I I get it but
you know when I thought it was funny I
just said in writing I suppose I didn't
understand because I'm like that's the
opposite of what I just said yeah it was
something else so I'm saying like you
have this Joker who's just a mentally
ill guy Who develops a following how
could that manifest realistic chaos
against the Batman you know or a Justice
League he's like I I can calculate
anyone's actions but this man is totally
erratic I can't I can't pick his move he
would have billionaire followers he like
like the far left he'd have he'd have
patrons who are ultra wealthy and they
would get word of like how to support
the Joker and they would be like yes the
system must be torn down and that's how
he he would develop these crazy Joker
lives matter he'd be like you'd see like
the Joker's face painted on like you
know
you know they'd have like a joker flag
of the stage just a rich guy who's
telling the Joker what to take down
because then he can bet stocks against
the company or or or here be a good one
a rich guy trying to manipulate the
Joker thinking his craze you know can
harm companies that would benefit Jokers
smarter than that he may be crazy but
the Joker ends up manipulating him back
taking his money oh man I I think they
could do a lot of great stuff pinning
the blame on him but I want to go I want
to go back in time to something that
that Ian said you mentioned that even
within someone's race there's great
diversity
well Ian I bring you now to a story from
bounding into Comics MCU fans claim
casting social Gomez as America Chavez's
colorist harass actress for being too
light-skinned wrong ethnicity well so
there you have it Ian yes you are
correct within different color people
there's great diversity but they don't
want that they want they want
simultaneously someone who looks just
like the person in the comic while also
saying that you can have a black woman
play like Anne Boleyn or something my
attitude is I honestly I don't care who
plays a character like when Idris Alba
was um
what's the guy's name in Marvel that
with the eyes you can see oh I can't I
can't remember
who's the guy who can see everything in
in Marvel I don't know he's the Norse
God yeah and people are complaining
because it's clearly endorsement it's
based on Norse mythology and he's not uh
and he's not exactly as pale as the as
the other ones in I'm one of those
people that I don't have a problem with
the race swapping other people
especially if I don't have a strong
connection to the source material
but so so people there's a lot of people
who are like it's Norse mythology and
Heimdall is a white man I'm like dude
he's an actor I don't care like there
are some instances where I can certainly
understand it if you're like you know
that one's a little too much when people
complain about Anne Boleyn being played
by a black that's because it's a real
person right it's a historical figure I
still kind of don't care that much
because I don't I I want someone's
performance to to yeah the best to play
Martin Luther King Jr yeah well there
lies the point I can make that happen
they will they right now the woke are
complaining that sochil Gomez is is the
wrong color yes but they're also the
same people who complain that or state
that you can have a black person play a
white character The Little Mermaid is
now yes uh but it only goes One
Direction it only goes Wonder because
they don't actually believe what they
believe and they are harassing the crap
out of this girl and it's like I feel so
bad I'm really young actors interested
in your experience now sorry to cut you
off there bro I want to yeah uh you were
there I mean yeah I mean um this is a
pretty new phenomenon in Hollywood right
and and so you go back in time and you
see movies from 10 years ago when
someone did something like this and now
they're getting sort of canceled for it
but the worst the worst case was
Scarlett Johansson her attachment was
going to get a movie made about the
trans about a trans person and and I
think you know those types of movies can
be helpful in uh normalizing and
behavior pattern things like that
whether you believe in it or not I'm
just saying it's a fact in her star
power and and so and so the the trans
activist came out out uh canceled the
movie
and now this movie is not going to get
made yeah ever uh uh there isn't a
foreign sales driving trans name now you
could say well okay hold it back until
there is one uh yeah that's not gonna
happen 15 years you know her name
recognition drives the ability for that
movie to make profit and and Benedict
Cumberbatch uh you know playing a gay
man it's all these different things it's
so exhausting so again just the the
reason why and I don't want the rules
but once the rules are created them's
the rules so look look at this real
quick it's this this Twitter user
Claudia amenibar says oh whitewashed
America shabba's I am so sorry what they
did to you what like literally what I
don't understand read some of the other
ones further down yeah well well they
get more insane who attacked who who
attacked her though was it the Aaron
rupars of the world or was it the well
you know who who who who made the first
okay America Chavez is a strong
confident queer afro boricua is it uh
bariqua with queer biological parents
and afro-bariqua adoptive parents I do
not know who this variant and Doctor
Strange is supposed to be but it's not
the character whose stories I've been
reading for a decade okay so when people
complain that Heimdall was played by a
black character I would like to see you
say the same thing now me personally I
don't care that I'm always play with I
think Idris Elba is fantastic they
talked about many people were like Idris
Elba should play James Bond I'm like
he'd actually be a really great James
he'd be great but the problem is these
people are acting in bad faith they
would not say like Daniel Craig would be
a great you know black panther they
would never say that nope because they
don't actually believe what they're
saying they're just racist lunatics I
would do the first half of my career in
the theater and it was very much about
like anyone can play any role is the
idea is like give actors a chance the
best actor should have the position then
I got into film and it was a different
different mentality it was more about
you want to be as realistic as possible
so if the person's supposed to be an
African-American you know descent dark
skin and it's not then it's very
confusing the film I like you pointed
out like when you're portraying real
people it's a very different thing than
portraying a comic book character or a
movie character and I get the people who
don't like it when the when the actual
characters get changed I get the the
dislike of race swapping but it just
doesn't bother me the same way bothers
other people is it have you found it to
be different what are you gonna say well
I just love when the left eats itself I
mean this is such a this is such a cell
phone she's got the lgbtq flag pin on
her chest and she's being canceled yeah
this poor actress Gomez is is no
right-winger you know uh Scarlett
Johansson is no right-winger this is
this is just this is just pathetic yeah
you want the one that cast her in that
role of somebody else oh there's a
there's a tweet up there where they said
these actors need to be better about not
accepting roles yes they're telling you
that you need to look at this and say
this opportunity could feed my family or
in her age like just could set me up
through college and I need to pass on
that because of ideological reasons do
you remember when just recently Peter
Dinklage came out yeah and said they're
making Snow White and the Seven Dwarves
I mean really think about what that
means and I'm and then a whole bunch of
uh actors Little People actors came out
and they were like you're taking our
jobs from us
roles in a decade yes in a seven Disney
movie roles opened up
I think we found out at a minimum a
hundred thousand dollars each person he
pulled the ladder up behind him he had
he's a tremendous career he's a great
actor he was in big movies he was in
Game of Thrones and now he's like stop
the only reason he was cast as uh Tyrion
Lannister is because Lana Tyrion is a a
little is it's con it's like a is that
character in the book and so they said
we want someone to fill that role how
about we just get a regular guy to play
that character if we can if it doesn't
matter who plays who it's all acting
well what what what movie is funnier
than elf so that scene in elf is so good
and it's just and he was and he was he
was asking for it great in it so I think
Ian mentioned this and we we I looked it
up I recommend you not look it up but uh
we were like Snow White and the Seven
dudes it's real it's real it's an adult
it's not what I thought it was no I just
thought you could change the name you
know I think I downloaded the wrong
snowboard foreign
so they had already anticipated that
this was going to be a problem before
they even went into production they're
going to make it seven magical creatures
all CGI
so a bunch of unicorns a large list of
people are gonna get paid just a lot
smaller amounts on the S on the special
effects uh castles but like a unicorn a
dragon like what do you what is it what
is it Snow White and the Seven magicals
because that's all they know so far is
like it was never going to be is Lord of
the Rings canceled because dwarves does
not reference little people it's a
reference to magical creatures like else
are we going to complain about elves
being too tall there's dwarf with a big
D which is fine but it's the little D
dwarves that yes you can't say because
that's yeah uh uh Lord of the Rings is
grandfathered in if it was a brand new
project no one Snow White's not
grandfathered in no it's not because
it's a new project look have you ever
looked at the thing that's like the
ginger side and and it's all the
red-headed characters that have been
removed and replaced with yeah so it's
like like that's what's going on right
now like uh like what they did with the
little mermaid they've recast a Little
Mermaid uh so all of these stories are
not grandfathered in you're going to
suffer either way here's what I don't
add to this so chill Gomez story America
Chavez
she was given the role of a queer woman
of color who's wearing an lgbtq pin and
now she is being attacked for it you
know what the ramifications of this will
be no one will ever want to play a
character that represents a marginalized
group because it'll damage their career
Like Scarlett Johansson like socio Gomez
and you know what they're doing it to
themselves this means in the future
they're going to be like we've got a
great character for the superhero film
who turns out to be a gay guy everyone's
gonna be like no I'm not going anywhere
near that sorry
whenever whenever they were uh releasing
being the Ricardos which is a fine movie
it's okay uh there was a lot of talk
about Javier Bardem playing Desi Arnaz
and there is this amazing article in uh
The Hollywood Reporter where Aaron
Sorkin talks about all of the different
folks the diversity coordinators that he
brought on to set so that he could get
away with casting Javier vardem as Desi
Arness this is incredible do you
remember what they did to when you
mentioned Gina Carano earlier when she
had her when she got fired from Disney
but before they fired her uh they tried
to do have her do a 40-person struggle
session with members of the lgbtq
community on a zoom call like that she
said I'll do it in person I'll talk to
these people one by one in person in an
auditorium I'm not going to be bullied
by 40 people on a zoom call that's
insane yeah I wouldn't do it
but the average actor like you said
she's Brave the average projectors like
yeah you can abuse me for the next hour
that's right if Gina Carano was an MMA
fighter yeah yeah she's she's uh she's
seen some some stuff she's not scared
she's taking a punch in her day and that
that's something to be said you know
often one of the things I bring up with
this um you know you mentioned people
crying about Donald Trump winning the
election and you're like what is what is
this I'm like well look if uh um if
you've never been in the sun you'll get
sunburned so these people are soft
little you know Blobs of of pink Jello
and then some other people have dealt
with hardship someone like Gina Carano
who's trained and fought and had to deal
with injuries and getting punched in the
face is going to shrug off the stupidity
of words I was someone who's grown up in
a pastel safe room with a padded walls
and bean bags all their lives well step
outside quivering and shaking and then
when someone says a naughty word they'll
go I'm being attacked it's violence a
lot of my friends from high school uh
none of them went in the military really
except for one guy and I at the time I
was like please do don't I was so afraid
for him because I thought he was gonna
get hurt and I didn't want it but now
today he's the most aware like doesn't
care about the stupid stuff he's fully
engaged in like what matters because he
saw combat once you see combat there's
no joke there's you know when MMA and
the military are both like that if you
like when all this stuff happened with
Joe Rogan the amount of MMA fighters
that came out in support of him because
they understand they understand that you
cannot just let these people bully you
well it's like when you get punched in
the face you kind of realize some things
don't matter all that much you know you
you when when you've dealt with real
hardship and if Gina hadn't done what
she did then there would be 10 other
people who came after her and showed
courage that never would have been able
to do it had she not had the courage in
that moment and it was the way you
encourage her to do it right away
absolutely that daily wire interview was
like three days later right it was it
was about a week later but but it was it
it was it was as fast as we could do it
but the announcement of the movie came
literally within 72 hours or even less
36 hours he even and uh you know it's it
we we tend Gina and I talk a lot a lot
about being the flak jacket right
walking out there coming on shows like
this talking about our our careers what
we've been through and taking the
bullets and showing courage in many ways
I'm not saying I'm courageous but I'm
saying in in order to give other people
courage
to come out and come work with us and
let their American flag fly I think
humility is so important because if you
can embarrass yourself in front of
people that's good man I wanna I wanna
bring up the story just because it's
it's in the realm of cancel culture and
it's hilarious so we have this once
again from bounding into Comics Pro
Tekken player tanakana dropped from
Esports team after saying short men
don't have human rights what saying um
men under 170 centimeters in height
don't deserve human rights according to
a report from Japanese news Outlet jcast
during a stream on February 15th
tanakana declared that men who are under
170 centimeters just over five foot five
don't have human rights adding they
should have bone lengthening surgery to
compensate for their lack of hype I uh I
do think there are a lot of people who
are deeply offended by that but uh I
think it's it's I hope she's joking
because if it is it's actually a funny
joke but I but now she's canceled before
saying it right as a five foot five
individual I'd like just like to say
that I'm extremely offended by this and
I think that her cancellation is exactly
she got exactly what she deserved uh and
I am not getting bone lengthening
surgery unless the government offers to
pay for you so as a 6'4 individual I do
not identify with your your problems you
can't understand my lived experience yes
yeah my height privilege you're you're
an oppressor don't you understand oh
yeah and you're oppressing yes see I
don't know when I'm gonna finally get my
due in the social hierarchy of identity
politics but I think being short means
I'm not at the exact bottom as a
straight white male but I'm getting a
little bit closer to the Top by being
under five six now now I will say I
think the issue is she was kind of
joking but in a more serious way like
it's one thing if the point of the joke
is that you're mocking like there's the
stories about Tinder where if a guy is
list his height is under six feet they
never get response responses if you're
mocking those people by saying it and we
know you're mocking the idea it's a
funny joke but if she is actually saying
like jokingly she does think they
deserve human rights but she's insulting
about it that's kind of a dick move you
know what I mean was she like streaming
and she just said it to the her
followers while she was streaming
because I could see like if you're just
gaming and you're like oh yeah I hate
these people they should all you know
what like just joking like it just comes
out as like a goofy little kid thing but
I don't know she's basically saying that
a guy went to deliver her food and he
like muttered and mumbled in front of
her house rang the doorbell then asked
her for her number and she said you know
she was scared because he knows where I
live so it's tough I don't want them to
start a fire or something and by acting
coldly he was short maybe only 165
centimeters she continued if he was tall
and muscular I might have given him my
contact information isn't that amazing a
rough life man yeah she wasn't insulted
by being hit on she was insulted by
being hit on by a short guy exactly now
imagine if it was a guy on stream no no
no no mind you she's gotten the boot
right so hey at least there's some
consistency there because I would say if
there was a dude and he was saying that
like a woman delivered his food and she
was morbidly obese and you know she
asked him for his in for his number and
he was was like oh get out of here yeah
he'd be banned instantly they'd be like
you're fat shaming and all that stuff I
actually think it's funny I wouldn't
have expected her to get any penalty for
mocking short dudes like that I'm
actually surprised this is a story at
all yeah yeah bet she got booted off her
team yeah I'm surprised that anybody
cared really I mean getting you're
getting kicked off a team I mean she
probably had a very expensive salary
that they needed to get rid of that's
true they found their reason they're
like short guys this really is that
really a reason to get rid of her like
it'll happen hold on this is the secret
that people need to understand when we
often hear about cancellations what
we're really hearing about is a company
trying to break a contract that they
can't bring exactly but they have
morality Clauses saying if you shock or
offend we can terminate your contract
immediately and this is what you get so
people people might be like oh why why
was Gina Carano fired maybe it really
had nothing to do with it yep maybe they
were just like we're paying her too much
and we just don't like her we need an
excuse for termination well it probably
was ideological lines that they wanted
to get rid of her this just gave them
the excuse and it's selectively enforced
because Pedro Pascal said stuff that was
way worse uh and he's of course he's
part of the in-group so he's allowed to
to exist in that sphere but they're like
we need a reason
that's creepy
the things he's he's posted and tweeted
about he's like a creepy guy I I
wouldn't have posted anything that any
one of them have posted but but the
truth is like I I kind of am a First
Amendment absolutist right and so I I
think just far away right but I also
have thicker skin than most people and
so you know I'm not offended by it uh I
I think I think in the case of Jeff
silker and and certainly maybe in this
case of this Tekken uh player I think
this is a money thing I also like that
it's a Tekken player yeah she's Jeff you
say she's part of a Japanese team is
that part of the story I think that was
mentioned that she's I know she says she
was Japanese
um if that's the case maybe there's a
cultural thing about hating on short
guys because I think Japanese people
might be generated nothing nothing in
life is worse than disingenuous morality
that is the worst thing in the whole
universe you know I I I think there's a
there's a big divide when we talk about
the Multicultural democracy the
constitutional republic I think a core
element of it is strength through
hardship strong men weak men or women or
whatever and you know you've got a lot
of soft people that can't handle the
real world they can't they it's they're
so dependent maybe it's independent
versus codependent is another way to
look at it for me I'm kind of like you
know if I was working in an industry in
fact this literally happened and they
were doing things I didn't like I'd be
like I won't do it you know when I
worked for Fusion
they they hire me on and they say we're
going to be nice Vice we want to be edgy
on the ground to report it but we're not
going to be as crass and crude and overt
with like sex drugs and rock and roll
and I'm like yeah totally get it like we
can get that that that on the ground
adventurous vibe that like cool hip
feeling you know whatever trying to get
while still being family friendly I'm
down and then six months later they're
like we decided we're gonna be woke and
I said okay well I'm not you know I'm
gonna keep doing my thing and they're
like then you can you know I tried
quitting they offered me more money and
then ultimately I'm like dude I'm not
gonna do it I don't care about you I
don't care about your company I would
much rather sit in my living room
playing video games and fall asleep than
deal with whatever it is you think you
can offer me so maybe that's just like
anti-social or whatever I don't I don't
I don't rely on on them for my
confidence or my self-esteem but I think
a big difference between you know the
two overarching political factions are
people who are desperate for recognition
and desperate for
um you know people to they they want
people to to think good things about
them and then there are people who are
just like yeah I literally don't care
what you think I'm gonna live my life
and be true to myself you know seven I
was doing Hollywood acting and and
YouTube and I started to get I was like
what you were saying I was seeking the
attention I wanted I was like when I win
an Oscar I want to thank my geometry
teacher for the 10th grade I was really
excited in my whole life and then I
started doing YouTube videos and I
started getting the attention elsewhere
and I realized okay it's not all about
the attention it's why are you getting
the attention what are you contributing
and that really changed my perspective
on everything after that I left that
industry pretty much I I want to change
that industry you know
yeah it's it's unchangeable it it's it's
it's Sodom and Gomorrah at this point
right it's it's it's it's gone they
think New York I think that's how
Hollywood got started they fled the mob
because the mob was trying to shut them
down in New York all these directors
1910 20 seconds I'm really inspired by
The Tool song you know uh uh just you
know uh enema is like you know learn to
swim yeah flush it all away it will wind
up in the my favorite Arizona bay baby I
was just thinking that praying for
Mayhem I'm praying for tidal waves in
California the federal government would
struggled to enforce tax law wow it was
a lot cheaper and easier to uh but I'll
give you an example Ian you know when
people say they want to change the
system it's like you're walking up to uh
the the Sears Tower in Chicago I know
it's called the Willis Tower we're from
Chicago and you're saying I want this
building to be my building by all means
you can accomplish that with great power
and time and dedication but that's like
trying to move a monolith such a great
structure build a new building start
your own building and so this is the way
I see it why should I go to Austin
everyone's like we're gonna go to Austin
and I'm like it's woke Central why would
I want to go to Austin no we're going to
get a field in the middle of nowhere in
West Virginia and we're going to build
our own building and we're going to
build our own thing out here because I'm
you know there's also people going to
Nashville I certainly think Nashville is
a way better bet than Austin but even
then I look at it and I'm just like I'd
be really happy just having my own
little free Dharma stand that we can
start up and we can build that around
because I'm not dependent upon anyone
else for what we seek to create
and that's and that's and that's the
that's the plan man yeah there has to be
a a happy medium between infrastructure
right uh and and uh Freedom right and
the ability to to sort of do what you
need so Nashville Dallas a couple of
these other cities are are great places
for that because you can you have enough
sort of talented people who can help you
fight the culture but remember someone
has to handle the Instagram account and
someone's got to handle the marketing
and someone's got to cut the trailer and
you got to be close enough to an airport
yeah otherwise I'd be in north northern
Maine yeah or Wyoming but uh legit we
did look at properties in rural
Pennsylvania Maine Montana Wyoming and
the big problem with all of it is they
actually have really great internet no
joke airports and so it's like how do we
actually bring people out to the middle
of nowhere well it's really difficult
but yeah with West Virginia you're close
enough to DC about an hour right so the
airport's right there so that's
something you know that ends up working
out
I guess we got to build an airstrip and
a Sound Stage and we can't the
The Sound Stage in
port and then we're set yeah
on top of the Sound Stage is that what
it was oh no helicopter helicopter pad
on top of the Sound Stage we got to
start investing helicopters
all right we're gonna go to Super Chat
so if you haven't already smash that
like button one honk is one like And
subscribe to the channel share the show
with your friends become a member at
timcast.com to help us grow and expand
we have actually taken pitches for uh
sitcoms and um you know fiction content
right now we're doing a timcast.com it's
mostly just journalism but we also do
have pop culture crisis bread of course
is the host so make sure you go to pop
culture crisis on YouTube and subscribe
to that uh to that show and Spotify uh I
I really do like uh to me the we cut
them up into segments for the YouTube
part but I love the full episode from
start to finish it's about an hour and a
half to an hour and 45 minutes and I
think you don't get the feel for it it's
a lot more fun if you listen to it from
there's there's stuff that gets cut out
from Clips yeah don't make the
follow-ups what do you do like what do
you guys dig into how do you get it
imagine like what we're doing here like
uh I go through the news like I try to
focus more in extremely like just just
on entertainment right so uh less about
the politics of it all like we do cover
it like you said the other night you
said politics uh politics are pop
culture I'm like you screwed me bro I ca
I can't do both right so uh we try to
cover the the more ridiculous stories I
leave out a lot of the time because I'm
like I don't need to make fun of this
story or talk about this story but like
we do a lot of reviews of movies we just
reviewed Uncharted last night we talk
about General news like we do a lot of
stuff on Kanye West because Kanye West
is uh one of the most interesting people
in the world to cover I talk movies a
lot uh everything going on within the
industry uh bounding into Comics all the
stuff on there uh we get everything from
there and it's just it's a lot of fun we
have I I think you know we approach
stuff from a political perspective and
sometimes drift into pop culture and
then you guys start from a pop culture
perspective and sometimes drift into
like cultural politics yes uh whenever
we get into it I try to like you learn
over time we're on like episode 58 right
now you you feel to the point where
you're getting too far into it and
you're like the average person isn't
going you know the the Normie the person
who doesn't understand that there is a
culture war going on isn't really going
to be enamored with the uh harder line
political takes that I might have on
these things so I try to draw attention
to them uh and bring them up in a way
that shares my perspective but doesn't
bludgeon you over the head with what my
beliefs are I don't think that's the
importance of it I'm more likely to call
out the stupidity of uh of projects my
new segment uh it's called who the hell
asked for this uh they're making a
Blue's Clues movie and they said it's
going to be like Spider-Man Noah home I
do ask who the hell asked for this uh a
Gumby movie just got sold
yes live action gumbies live action live
action so I I see that story I
appreciate people I read that article
I'm like oh God this is awesome I can
get 20 minutes out of this easy all
right so we're going to let's get these
super chats but again uh smash the like
button and subscribe to pop culture
crisis on YouTube all right key Lloyd
says when can we expect Ben to start
doing Stanley style Cami cameos in the
Productions
well first we got to get him to visit
set right so if we can get him to visit
set then I will throw them in a movie uh
secretly you know maybe he'll be the guy
that opens the door or the driver of the
yeah can I get you something to drink
sir that obsess has got to be no you got
to give him a roll he has no business
doing right like you know being a
bodyguard bodyguard yeah yeah exactly
perfect but like a cameo you know just
because people would be like oh and it'd
be fun oh yeah he's starting to act in
more of the daily wire uh Instagram
videos so uh you know maybe your wish is
going to come true you got to see the uh
the daily wire Cinematic Universe yeah
so you get these movies and then they
get connected at the end of like shut in
someone gets shut in in a school supply
closet
I make Gina the is Gina the Robert
Downey Jr
absolutely yes she is yeah but you know
considering the time gap between you
know uh Tara on the Prairie I think it's
called right and then these other films
she's just very old she lives forever so
she's always her in every different no
no generation of reality at the end of
Terror on the Prairie she falls into a
hole with magic ice and freezes her and
then she wakes up in you know 1970
whatever and yeah she just plays her
great great granddaughter did you guys
ever read The Dark Tower Stephen King
novels I mean doorways that lead you to
other Realms I saw the movie movie was
fun all right let's read some more we
got just comply says the RCMP horse
trampled an elderly lady and a guy on a
scooter tonight what are these
chuckleheads doing I am ashamed of my
government yo I have seen this stuff
more times than I care to recall I was
up in Montreal during student protests
and I see the cops were throwing they
have these things I wrap they're called
but they're like flashbangs with pepper
spray in them so they bang and then the
the whole area like stings it was a
really I've never seen something like
that before it's kind of weird but
that's at least how it was described to
me and I I was like is that is that true
and then I read some stuff online about
it might have just been activists
claiming it but one of these flashbangs
went off and then I walked past it it
was like walking through a cloud of
pepper spray so look I've seen peaceful
protests on the left and uh they've had
bad cops I've seen more than my fair
share of riots though so I tend to be
like well you know look sometimes people
lose control now what we're seeing
though I think a lot of people on the
right are starting to experience that
these cops are indiscriminate they'll
[ __ ] trample an elderly lady man
all right let's uh let's grab some more
Super chats let's let's get into this
okay
what is this one
James Roger says hey Tim how can I
determine who is telling the proper
narrative on this I have friends in
Canada who call this a national
embarrassment and they need to go the F
home but then you tell us the opposite
who's right well that's just a matter of
opinion if you um look I trust Aviva fry
for instance because he's like a regular
dude he's an honest guy he's got a
YouTube channel he goes down there and
he live streams all of this and I'm like
I think that's inaccurate or Fair
representation for the most part there's
probably some nuances and things you
don't see but a dude that I know and
like telling me live walking around is
infinitely more trustworthy than the
Toronto Sun or whatever saying it's a
bunch of white supremacists who are
stealing phone food from the homeless
that's insane and not true and it
doesn't even have to be just that bad
it's the stuff where they they call it
anti-vaxxer protests rather than just
saying that it's about mandates right
which is a much simpler it slips by
people they don't realize so the average
person who doesn't have a political bias
here just says look at these crazy
anti-science people who are protesting
science Trayvon Martin story was alive
the Michael Brown story was a lie the
the guy in Baltimore forgot his name
that was a lie George Floyd Ahmed Arbury
lie lie lie endless Justice Mallette
another lie then we get the bigger lies
Russia gay Ukraine gate lie lie it just
keeps happening so I just I don't I'm
I'm done you know I still read a lot of
these sources and I try and fact check
them because there's some stuff you
can't get anywhere else and it's not all
bad but it's too too often the overt
political stuff and activism is just
agenda driven and full of crap
but let's grab some more Super chats
people are talking about Ukraine skin
pretty pretty uh pretty crazy I heard
the Russians pulled the troops off the
border is that right
yeah they just were there just been
establishing training exercises and now
they pulled back I don't know what to
believe
okay let's uh Turnpike paladin says hey
Dallas any updates you can share on
breakfast with the dirt cult so there's
this great book written by this guy in
Oklahoma
uh names uh Samuel Finlay and it's this
amazing amazing story of the first
Insurgency into Afghanistan you know go
on 15 years ago and I have shown
interest in getting it made and there is
this wild rabid contingency online that
shows up anywhere I go and asks what's
the latest with this movie the truth is
I want to make it really really badly
it's a tough movie to make uh it's about
a soldier who comes back from the war
and falls in love and basically uh
struggles through it as a young man so
it's it's a drama with war elements to
it it's a terrific book everyone should
go by it's called breakfast with the
dirt cold cool cool all right let's see
we got here
Mordred says so I have to give my first
Super Chat to Ian for his consistent
natural 20s yesterday normally he just
raises my blood pressure but he
absolutely killed it yesterday much love
man you got it brother and I think a lot
of people should definitely check out
yesterday's episode where we had a
conversation with Stephen Marsh on the
next civil war he has what I would
describe as an establishment world of
you so there was some arguments but I
think the conversation was absolutely
worth listening to especially if you
want to hear opinions you'll disagree
with uh I think people should check it
out it wasn't really a news driven story
as we often do with like you know a lead
story it was more of a conversation with
someone we we disagree with about a lot
of things and people certainly in super
chats had their opinions it was an
example that it's not so much about
trying to convince information people of
information more that just that you are
able to communicate with people that
have different types of information I
think I think it was both of us
recognizing from different points of
view that this is inevitable that uh you
know the point I made to him when he
said when when will Americans realize
this conflict is tearing you guys apart
and it's going to lead something worse
and then I said do you you're he's from
Canada and I was like you like your
socialized medicine okay we'll abolish
that Canada will go full Private health
care do we have peace and he was like I
see your point like there you know our
world view is very much Freedom
meritocracy we're not going to give up
civil rights and freedom to people who
want to take it away it's just never
going to happen they can think the same
thing but I'm just going to say it one
more time they live in a cult crackpot
world view and you know his point was
he's like but they say the same thing
about you and I'm like I know and
they're wrong because Jesse Smith was a
lie Michael Brown was a lie Trayvon
Martin was a lie all Ahmed Aubry was a
lie all of those stories George Floyd
another lie a black lives matter
activist was arrested for attempting to
assassinate a Jewish Democrat about a
week after he posted black nationalist
anti-semitic uh you know support for
this organization he gets bailed out on
a hundred thousand dollars Kyle
Rittenhouse goes to prison goes to jail
for a couple months two million dollars
bail is smeared and demonized in the
media yo I'm sick of the lies one side
is very clearly lying one side just
might be wrong sometimes I think it's
anyway that being said go find me taken
down for college exactly exactly and
then you've got you've got to uh
GoFundMe allowing antifa to fundraise to
literally steal property to seize a
building
but let's read some more atherin zala
says Ian rolling a 20 with your tie-dye
sweater looks nice and fluffy rolling a
one thinking the queen can put a stop to
it up here she has a figurehead at best
wow you might want to you want to
reconsider that statement that the queen
is a figurehead at best she's the queen
of England
um but Tim bought me this sweater thank
you
we went to uh we're at the mall and I
saw that and I was like that looks like
a sweater Ian would wear it he was right
all right let's see um Rudy says hey
Brett what do you think of Nintendo
Direct uh Miracle would be our co-host
Miracle would be the better person to
ask about that I am a vintage video game
collector I am not a modern day gamer oh
vintage gamer
all right Jason Lindholm says I did
security for Man of Steel and part of
Batman vs Superman the division was
apparent then left versus right some of
the Cali crew hated being in Illinois
yeah well Illinois is a red state with a
blue City in it as as basically every
every one of these states Minnesota is a
lot like that too uh St Paul and
Minneapolis are very blue and then the
rest of the state just kind of has I
mean Ohio is like that too Northeast
Ohio is very blue there there are no
blue states only blue cities in red
States it's very much a city like you
said City versus rural is a big part of
what these uh yeah here's a good one
boof says good name by the way Dallas do
you see masculinity returning to cinema
anytime soon if today's young man ever
watched a John Milius movie they would
poop themselves and cry well a few
things here the answer is yes uh we will
solve this soon uh strangely you know
we're only reacting at this point to
most of the stuff being written out of
Hollywood so you know our first three
movies with the daily wire are female
leads fighting back but that's also
because they're cool you know in in
terms of John Milly's uh his daughter
Amanda who's been on your show is
someone as someone I am desperate to get
into the director's chair uh I bugger
all the time so we'll we'll we'll we'll
get this going you know I'd like to
recreate oh we're gonna say well I was
gonna say the last thing is uh uh
masculinity because you know the great
Breitbart said uh politics is Downstream
of culture we have to show solid heroic
masculine energy back in movies again
and we'll get there
but no no but and feminine energy
I think feminine energy is missing more
than masculine energy dude absolutely we
just covered this the other day because
Hannah Claire she said why is everything
reboots and why are they all female lead
reboots and we went as I found a
feminist article of what you know it's
like where can I find a take on this
that's that you wouldn't think is the uh
the typical take and it's talking about
how they're not not telling female
stories they're telling male stories
with feminine with female characters
exactly so they're essentially erasing
the female experience from these uh in
the new Terminator movie She denigrates
motherhood and turns it down and said
and says uh having kids is basically bad
that everything about femininity
motherhood uh the ability uh what it
means to be a woman in modern age is
denigrated in Hollywood in favor of
telling much easier simpler masculine
stories and just inserting females there
and it's it's white always comes off as
inauthentic it's why it never works well
I thought Mad Max nailed it uh Fury Road
Charlize Theron was basically the lead
and she was powerful and almost exuded
the masculine energy except Max was
insane but still you could see his
humanity and but throughout the movie
you see the man come back and it's like
the power of the woman to help the man
become masculine was just such a good
good dichotomy Mad Max Fury Road is a
woman in a man's role no Max is still
Max he's just lost his mind so she helps
so you don't understand uh the masculine
role of going to war going to combat
risking their lives to save the day
that's that's the masculine archetype
there is
Fury is is not a feminine archetype it
is just it is it is a role written for a
man with a woman but it's I think it's
like if a woman in a post-apocalyptic
apocalyptic situation found her man
incapable of protecting himself she
would become her Fury she would become
that woman
because the story is femininity gets
sacrificed when there's not a strong
masculine presence and then but then you
can see the femininity in Max like the
the the the like the growth and the
child no no I I I think uh I'm I'm with
Tim on this uh uh I think Mad Max Fury
Road while it's a such a fun movie to
watch I think the story itself the plot
is is is not aging very well and we got
a uh we got an amazing article written
about us a couple of days ago from a guy
named John Simley just awesome we're all
just so enjoying it it's a total hit
piece but we love that kind of stuff so
we're reading this article just quoting
lines from it to each other and
everything like that and it's just
amazing and and in it he was so angry
that there was religious I can
pornography that there was a femininity
things like that and and you know that
we you know it's just it's a blast right
we're going to keep doing this and solve
these things remember we're just getting
started right we should do something
about Islam and Christianity and like
bringing them together so I I thought
Wonder Woman was actually uh really
great I wouldn't go as far to say that
um Wonder Woman was an overtly feminine
role because she's still in war with her
Shield but there was there was something
more motherly about her perspective on
war and ending it versus it was the
idealism versus the realism and her and
Chris Pine having the argument about how
to stop war from happening she was
overtly idealistic we end the god of war
and it's done he's like no sometimes
people fight I really really enjoyed
that but in terms of actually getting
femininity right I think the issue is
Hollywood keeps saying we're gonna we're
gonna make a strong female character so
write Rambo but naked a woman is like
yeah but that that's Rambo's mom well we
did we did Rambo it we we did Rambo
adjacent as a woman uh in some ways in
run height light we did everything they
asked us to do and we got attacked for
it I love the movie it's it's uh it's
it's uh it's a great movie but but we
followed the rules and still got
attacked let me let me read the Super
Chat here we got Expedition says Dallas
I'm a great first A.D with good credits
and have directed episodic I left
Hollywood because of my beliefs want to
use my talents and skills outside the
system for Outlets like daily wire any
ideas of how I can connect absolutely
the easiest way to get to me is DM me on
bonfire Legend Instagram at bonfire
Legend So I'm not available anywhere
else I'm certainly not on the hellscape
of Twitter uh I'm too I'm too young for
Facebook uh and keep an eye out for
Expedition Pangea because I'm sure
you'll get inundated but they were the
ones who made the requests great I I do
want to before you go on point out that
if they're looking for a series that
does have a good amount of masculinity
in it uh go check out Reacher on Amazon
Prime uh excellent that was a good one
excellent I I was like when we did that
when we covered the show I'm like okay
guys I'm gonna Fanboy for about 25
minutes here so you're gonna have to
you're gonna have to like settle in
while I just sing this this Show's
Praises for about 25 minutes and that
dude is allowed to be both hyper
masculine extremely smart uh he even
gets the woman in the show which is
almost like a No-No in in today's day
and age uh and the woman the female
character is both strong but also
allowed to be feminine uh and act she
protects the children later on at the
end of the show it's it almost is the
per in current year as close to perfect
as you can get to do that type of
character I thought the show was
fantastic fantastic does the guy have a
flaw uh You Gotta Give a gigantic flaw
to the hero if you want to be super
powerful he does yeah Kryptonite oh no
I'm kidding he's actually he's actually
um I would say that I don't want to
spoil anything but I would say he's
short he's he's a um five five no no
he's six I'm kidding characteristics
five but I would say for Reacher he is
all of these really great things but um
he takes
um what's the right way to describe it
his uh uh like honor more is more
important than his success okay Pride
prize is a big problem so so I don't
want to spoil too much but he's more
interested in killing those who've
wronged them than solving the case
vigilante yeah it's dangerous no it's
not vigilante it's like
slow down thanks Tim we need to capture
this guy to learn who controls the
system and he goes no bang and kills him
so he's he has no patience it's it's
he's more interested in in slight in
retribution than he's in solving the
case he even like there's early on in
the show he shoots two dudes in the back
and she's like these are Exit Wounds and
he's like there to killed me oh well
like it's very morally gray but the best
part about the characters in fact he is
almost Sherlock's home's-ish in the way
he describes when he when he solves a
crime this care that character in modern
day at his size and this dude is
enormous Alan Richardson is either going
to be allowed to be hyper masculine big
hyper masculine or he's gonna allowed to
be smart he can't be both and they let
the dude be both and that was incredible
I thought Sherlock his uh he's a heroin
addict which I thought made such a great
that was his big flaw was he's a drug
addict but it makes the character like
when he succeeds you're so happy for him
because he overcame his problem
the character's a bit of a loner I don't
know if you consider that a flaw but he
definitely uh has like attachment issues
and it's played as like a part of his
character to be very much uh separate
from society he's traveling his own Road
and that plays a part of the of the
character I don't know if it's
necessarily a flaw but it's definitely
an element of who he is so let me read
this one Murph says Dallas could there
ever be a silent movie I've been
thinking about how you could make a
movie work with no dialogue it probably
couldn't work but it would be a
challenge there's an obvious answer to
this
but did you want to address it first I
would say a silent movie in in many ways
you know I made bone Tomahawk and it had
I think two minutes of score right and
most of the time people weren't talking
or or in some of the scenes it was very
quiet so that that's that's a that's a a
version of how far it could go
um I would say that a silent movie could
work if it was experimental and you
found some way for it to still be
appealing to a commercial audience in a
modern era there's there's two really
simple answers I mean um we had we just
had that movie I thought it was terrible
whether you can't make a sound what is
it with the quiet place quiet place
which was very little dialogue and uh
correct me if I'm wrong I haven't seen
it in a while but Apocalypto
yeah there's almost no doubt certainly I
think there's literally no dialogue in
Apocalypto right or no yeah they're
they're speaking in in their native
language but but they're not they're
very little yeah
um but a quiet place you know I got
bored by that I didn't like it I it's
just it was too quiet right well you
know they're not joking
it's mentally painful so there's a
there's a room it's they call it the
quietest in the world and when P they
say I think the record for setting it is
45 minutes so you'd have to watch the
movie in that room no and really get the
full effect when you go into this quiet
room it's got uh these spikes that come
out of the walls it absorbs almost all
sound it's physically and it's like
mentally painful for you to be in a room
with no sound oh and I'll tell you this
I've been in soundproof rooms we have a
sound booth where like all the sound
absorbing stuff on the wall I've built
soundproof rooms for recording I cannot
stand sitting in in soundproof rooms
because what happens is what you don't
realize one thing that really becomes
apparent when you talk in a room you
don't realize you are hearing an echo
because the wall the sound bounces off
the walls when you go into a fully
soundproof room it's a weird feeling
you'll talk and then the sound erases
the moment it's it's weird it's sharp
almost no I would call it adult I I
think it's like it feels like I've got
giant gym mats smashing my head yeah
okay yeah and I'm just like
couldn't imagine going into that world's
quietest room you know
all right let's see we got here
Arturo says the thing about Batman
villains is that the conflict they
create is not just violence it's
psychological each time each of them is
a study in human psychosis
oh that was thanks your your plug is
rubbing on your headphones I think
thanks or I don't know what that is
actually there's a buzz happening I
think it's your power your your power
cable okay it's this hoodie yeah it's
all this hot static electricity yeah so
uh Batman villains not just violence is
psychological each of them is a study in
human psychosis the Rogues gallery of
Batman it is really great Paul Dano as
the Riddler is probably the part I'm
most excited about really it's Paul Dano
yeah oh I'm very Colin Farrell as
penguin no yes in basically full body
suit makeup
um really and they're doing a us they're
getting giving him his own show too on
on HBO Max to do beforehand okay yeah
they're gonna do a penguin spin-off with
him yeah probably so he doesn't have to
wear the suit the whole time it'll be a
prequel where he's just Oswald cobblepot
body positivity yep uh John Cena was
fantastic in Peacemaker the best part
miracle miracle can't stand John Cena
I'm like this he was designed he was
literally Built For This role it's
fantastic and James Gunn was like he's
designed for James Gunn style of writing
which blends uh very heartfelt
meaningful moments with really crude an
over-the-top humor and he Blends it
together so perfectly that John Cena was
the absolute perfect cast I think the um
Fast and Furious Cinematic Universe is
the best Cinematic Universe and I will
and John Cena in the latest film I was
kind of like you know take it or leave
him but uh so I was kind of like yeah
John Cena but Peacemaker I watch and I'm
like he Nails it it is Peacemaker is a
fun show uh I think they did a fantastic
job and you know I just absolutely love
the end when I was like oh it's the
Democratic establishment of the evil
villains I'm like okay you've won me
over with your politics
I'm half kidding but I at first I
started to roll my eyes when they
started to like you know monologue I
told you about the line at the end like
at the end where I'm like Proto fashion
spoilers no that's not a spoilers the
line that she says all right that's like
a key line at the end of the film so
this is like a political movie sewing
division uh by John Cena the CCP guy no
chill no no no no for sure like John
Cena coming out and you know doing that
China bit not not good not a fan and
then we're like and then they call it P
let's just put this Peacemaker
everything's fine guys no no Peacemaker
is a violent murderer a psychopath
the character he was like I will kill
anyone for peace that's cool he's insane
so he's like but I cherish peace with
all my heart and I don't care how many
men women and children I have to kill to
get it that's right and I love when he's
with vigilante and they're talking about
how they have to kill how they used to
kill people and it's like sometimes you
gotta kill the murderer or a graffiti
artist jaywalker
they're just insane people yeah they're
not they're villains it's funny though
all the characters in the show are
insanely uh over the top bad and that's
the best part of it except for adebayo
who who plays basically the straight man
to the rest of the character she's
looking at all these people and she's
like what the hell is going on who are
these people I love it yep
all right let's see what do we got here
let's uh read this one
agent juice cartoon says Dallas I admire
you helping create a viable parallel
Hollywood I wanted the same for
animation I know you do live action but
any way to reach out to you or your
studio even if only for advice
I would say uh absolutely reach out to
me the daily wire is so pumped about
doing animation right they've got a
couple of projects in the works a lot of
conversation a lot of of Financial
Resources being put forth for this so
please reach out to me I'll I'll hook
you up we're actually working on a
couple video games actually it's it's
hard to get going because we're not a
video game company but um we we have uh
had for a while a a playable I guess
you'd call it an alpha and uh it's it's
a I don't give away too much but I did
post on Instagram like almost a year ago
it's based on freedom Tunes animation
and I don't I don't think we've said too
much about what what the plan is but
it's going to be like a roguelike combat
game and so the goal is to I'll just say
this the game mocks far left extremists
and so as they deserve it's it's cartoon
violence so nothing over the top but it
mocks it mocks political extremists in
general and that's kind of the idea we
want people to play games and and make
fun of the crazies in the idiots and not
want to be a part of that so we're
working on stuff like that too
I've read a lot that Pixar animators are
leaving because of basically Disney
giving uh preference to their Animation
Studio over Pixar yeah you're a guy
who's been there for you know 15 20
years and and you're expecting to get
your turn and they're not getting
theater releases for any of that stuff
they're putting all the Pixar stuff
straight to Disney plus well Disney
animation movies go to the theaters are
those uh creators leaving and I know a
lot of them are creating their own
projects outside there uh is there a
possibility of those animators coming
over yeah uh uh you know animation is a
new space for all of us we're we've been
live action guys for so long but but
it's an important space especially uh
because it could be comedic it can be
for uh younger audiences all kinds of
things and it tends to get less scrutiny
from the mainstream like I've noticed
like you can get away with more DC and
DC animated movies are always far
superior to DC uh live action movies
because they're allowed to be let they
don't have to take as many liberties
with the source material they can stay
true to what the actual story was
supposed to be and it gives because of
the the reduced scrutiny yeah they're
allowed to create what they want let me
disappoint by your actor be in the right
color Constantine is an incredible
character and the Constantine film I
liked it but they missed so much
Constantine in in the justice league
dark films in as a character in the
comics is is awesome the the Canna
raised version is not nearly as awesome
now as its own Universe I thought it was
a great movie yeah but it's just not
Constantine you know what I mean Matt
Ryan does the live action real well on
TV but he's not he's not a move they
wouldn't cast a TV actor to play that in
a film at this point right well they
would want a bigger name but Daredevil
uh I I love uh Charlie Cox's Daredevil
he's uh he's the exception Academy and
he also said that he wants to do that
character for like the rest of his life
like he's like I do like 10 more years
of this if he can so hopefully they'll
not that I have any faith that Disney
will be able to recapture the magic of
Netflix uh Daredevil that Cameo was
fantastic in no way home he's like how
did you do that I'm a really good lawyer
I will I will say this out loud so we
can start to manifest it but how crazy
would Hollywood go if Tim Poole and the
daily wire collaborated on a movie
together regret I mean I'm down I don't
know what can we do animation live
action comedy drama I don't care we've
got to figure it out because that would
melt their face I'd be honored it would
be an honorable daily wire spun up a
master class on how to act how to act
how to how to basically attack because
there's a lot of people I think want to
come through this right now yeah and if
they understand I have a tiny version of
it happening right now I call it bonfire
State University and we bring about 10
people to all of our movie sets and we
put them in new roles and they're very
young and they're very hungry and
they're they're excited to learn so they
get to see and they get to see me and
Gina Carano and our directors Michael
polish how normal people are well that
but also like how to conduct yourself on
set like that is a that is a skill and
I'll tell you it takes time we're really
hurry up and wait we're really working
on it daily wire needs to fund a like 2
000 episode anime series so just like
Dragon Ball take it one piece you know
and I'm I'm actually half kidding I
don't expect a daily wire to find anime
but I think there's a lot of that
there's like the the anime right meme
you gotta do it oh a thing where a guy
can go inside his own body and then he
has to fight the stuff in his own body
to fix his body if he gets hurt right
right the treat like Inception come on
come on I I think that's been done in
many ways but it's more as a subplot
yeah yeah be a subplot it'd be like his
power Inner Space the rights to Honey I
Shrunk the Kids
and get Rick Moranis I think I Shrunk
the Kids was written by Stuart Gordon
the great horror horror director
well I would I would uh I would love to
do a movie We're not I don't know what
we would or could do you know you tell
me and we're we're game for whatever so
sci-fi yeah yeah we got to do sci-fi it
is the number one thing we are not doing
now that we have to do Star Trek the
Next Generation is my all-time favorite
show there was a period where I was like
referencing it non-stop then I started
watching Stargate sg1 which is also an
amazing show
um Star Trek man the next generation was
I've got was awesome ideas have you ever
heard of a Charged black hole because
you're about to baby it's a real thing
let's use it for teleport let's dude I'm
gonna be warping around the Galaxy my
idea for everybody listening was a movie
like you know Harold and Kumar or Dude
where's my car but it's about Ian trying
to get to a graphene conference and then
you know see a spaceship no no it's got
to be it's got to be normal to make to
make those jokes so like you know Ian
gets an invitation in the mail and it's
like you're hereby invited to the latest
Revelation in graphene technology and
then he goes on wacky shenanigan
Adventures trying to get trips on a
banana peel yeah literally falls on the
stairs and then like you know and then
gets picked up by the mafia and they
think he's the delivery guy but he's
like I'm just trying to get to the
graphene conference like is that a code
word for something and they're like
threatening him and he's like oh and
then you know it finally he makes it
there and you know somehow he's not the
CEO of a company he's a millionaire and
he's on a jet pack and he's like my
life's crazy and graphene you know
yeah yeah that's my plan that's my idea
I'm actually starting Ian as you think
you could do it all right everybody I'm
just trying to so we're gonna graphene
man we're gonna have a configuration
about what movie we can do but uh in the
meantime smash that like button
subscribe to the channel become a member
at timcast.com to help support all of
our work check out the daily wires films
I'm really excited when I heard daily
while I was getting into movies I was
like it's exactly what we need you can
follow us at timcast IRL on Instagram or
anywhere else you can follow me at
timcast Dallas you want to shout out
anything specifically yeah uh you can
find our new movie shut in uh at Daily
wire on their app or at shut in.com uh I
just have to say this uh what Ben
Shapiro and Jeremy boring and all the
guys over at Daily wire doing is so
important in giving me uh the
opportunity to make these great movies
for us to help Gina Carano and folks
like her continue to make movies outside
the system it's really really really
special uh I can say that there's a lot
of love for Tim cast over there air and
vice versa I think uh folks who who are
sort of pushing back on the left's
narrative the more we can do together
get in touch with each other uh that's
great this is gonna this is gonna be so
big and just understand like we are
killing ourselves to make great movies
and I tell you tear on the Prairie the
Gina Carano movie is one of the best
movies I've ever made I I just gotta
issue a correction uh No No Love No No
Love No No pure jealousy Envy I look at
what the daily wire is doing and I'm
like man we gotta step our game up we
got it we gotta get on this movies shows
and all that stuff no but but I kid I'm
a big fan of everything they're
accomplishing and they're and they're
and they're working on and I gotta admit
I absolutely am jealous of how they're
they're doing movies I'm like man I want
to do the same thing so we can build
culture and we can challenge the BS and
build parallel systems and have our own
spaces so so absolutely amazing stuff
Brett you want to shout out yes guys uh
you can follow me at Brett dasovich on
Instagram but more importantly go follow
pop culture crisis on YouTube like the
Channel please we appreciate that
subscribe the channel but also follow us
on Spotify it's also on Amazon music on
Apple podcast and on Pandora and we do
episodes Monday through Friday me and
miracle Sam follow us over there and I
will say you can follow me Ian
crossland.net um and keep in mind I
think one of the wonderful things about
the entertainment industry is that it's
very cohesive there is competition to
get into the industry but once you're
there and you're working on a project
the the better you make everyone around
you look and do the more that you're
going to end up working in the ad
industry it's very it's a very
team-based orientation and and so it's
very very easy to do once you get into
it come join us get involved I'll see
you later thank you all guys all very
much for joining us oh I adjusted my
camera a little too far up I got a tall
guy over there the toughest head okay
there we go
um I want to thank you guys for joining
us very much I know the news has been
getting a little dark lately so it was
really really fun to be able to talk
about some slightly other things and the
culture is so important I really
appreciate what you guys are doing and I
really enjoy what Brett and Miracle are
doing over on pop culture crisis you
guys may follow me and Twitter and
minds.com at Sarah patchlights you can
check out us at youtube.com cast Castle
because we don't do the shows on the
weekend but cast Castle is every day and
that's our Vlog in Shenanigans and joke
Channel where we have a lot of fun so
subscribe there thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time